[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus sur
rt france pour deux heures d'émission
tout en direct nous décrypterons comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 29 janvier
tout aussi déterminé mais moins nombreux
dans la rue pour cette huitième journée
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
aujourd'hui contre le projet de réforme
des retraites qui a commencé son
parcours législatif
à la veille de l'ouverture sur la
conférence sur le financement la cfdt
seul grand syndicat à soutenir un
système universel réclament des avancées
sociales payées me netanyahu seront à
moscou au lendemain de l'annoncé du plan
perron et au moyen-orient de donald
trump le premier ministre israélien doit
être exposé au chef du kremlin le texte
du président américain rejetée par les
palestiniens et une grande partie de la
communauté internationale
la belgique privée de gouvernement
depuis plus d'un an une situation loin
d'être inédite pour le plat pays
si les affaires courantes sont très
ténues
ni budget voté ni politique engagé une
impasse politique qui fait resurgir
l'hypothèse d'un référendum sur la
partition du pays
l'accord sur le break site ratifier une
large majorité par le parlement européen
le grand saut et imminent le royaume uni
quittera l'europe ce vendredi viendront
ensuite les négociations sur sa future
relation avec les vingt-sept le plus dur
est devant nous avertit paris mais nous
ne serons jamais loin pour mais quand
elle
la présidente de la commission
européenne
[Musique]
huitième jour de mobilisation nationale
interprofessionnelle donc contre la
réforme des retraites manifestations en
région et dans la capitale à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats la cgt et fo en tête
ils étaient 180 milles à paris selon la
cgt
treize mille selon le ministère de
l'intérieur près de 1000 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur moins que la
dernière fois leurs objectifs le retrait
du texte adopté vendredi en conseil des
ministres rassemblement plutôt calme
malgré treize interpellations parmi les
manifestants jean luc mélenchon de la
france est soumise et yves veyrier
secrétaire général de la force ouvrière
évidemment ne placer ici de montrer que
on est solidaires mais ce taux il faut
dire une chose le mouvement est en train
de se diffuser en profondeur dans le
pays et on oblige le gouvernement à une
espèce de contre-offensive en mouvement
donc tous les jours il doit la
question'' gamme matière à réformer mais
il faut réformer pour faire partir les
gens à 60 ans la nuit était déjà 47
retour sachez qu'on ne laissera pas
détourner l'attention du système
universel de retraite par points par
cette conférence nous notre objectif
c'est de finir par convaincre
on va peser on va aller voir les
parlementaires en leur disant y compris
vous même vous êtes traité à la légère
le conseil d'état souligne qu'il ya
beaucoup d' ordonnances prévues dans le
projet de loi autrement dit y compris on
passe d'une certaine manière par dessus
le rôle du législateur le parlement et
avec une visibilité absolument flou de
ce que sera finalement où il
concrètement le droit à la retraite
demain avec ce projet de loin d'un côté
station dans la rue donc mais également
à l'assemblée nationale si le conseil
d'état se montre critique
quatre groupes d'opposition demandent
une saisine du conseil constitutionnel
aux sujets de l'étude d'impact jugée
incomplète
le pcf présente un contre projet
prévoyant un âge de départ à la retraite
à 60 ans les républicains eux de vendre
un nouveau texte et dénoncent la
précipitation et l'amateurisme du
gouvernement
exécutif lui appelle au calme écoutez le
premier ministre je n'ai pas peur du
débat parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat ce qu'ils disent
ce qu'ils disent que ce débat devrait
prendre la forme d'un champ de braise ne
disent pas quelque chose auquel je crois
nous allons tenir le calendrier que nous
nous sommes fixés monsieur le président
marseille et le calendrier que nous
avons fixée c'est effectivement la
présentation d'un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres c'était vendredi
dernier et l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale puis par le sénat au cours du
premier semestre de ce texte de façon à
ce que nous puissions espérer
je ne veux pas préjuger de l'issue du
débat parlementaire mais c'est en tout
cas l'objectif que nous nous fixons une
adoption du texte avant l'interruption
estivale et pour en parler nous sommes
avec marie claire cailletaud dirigeante
confédéral cgt à bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france à ses côtés christian
saint-palais avocat merci à vous aussi
m d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france donc huitième journée de
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
beaucoup moins de monde dans les rues
par rapport aux autres manifestations on
imagine que ça devient peut-être
compliqué pour les salariés de prendre à
chaque fois des jours pour aller
manifester ce qui n'entame certainement
pas la détermination en tout cas au vu
des sondages qui donnent toujours une
majorité de français contre ce projet de
réforme comment vous expliquer en tout
cas cette baisse de participation dans
les rues alors déjà moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'à mobilisation
elle ne compte pas uniquement au nombre
de manifestants il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de choses qui se passent dans ping qui
sont pas forcément tout médiatisé
maintenant beaucoup de professions dans
le secteur de l'énergie dans dans le
secteur ports et docks de métal
métallurgie enfin dans beaucoup
d'endroits il se passe des choses est
effectivement bon les et les
manifestations sont peut-être inégal
c'est vrai que c'est on savait par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui manifesté
mercredi c'est moins simple par rapport
aux enseignants ou voilà ou aux jeunes
évidemment ça finit par compter quand on
a des payes qui arrivent avec des
chiffres de zéro voire négatif avec le
prélèvement à la source des impôts il ya
des fossés compliqué on est obligé de
reprendre le travail mais ça veut pas
dire que la détermination n'est pas là
je pense que détermination n'est
vraiment ancrée ancrée chez les
grévistes chez les salariés et puis un
fait quand même extraordinaire qui états
unis c'est l'opinion publique qui
continue à tenir et à rejeter
massivement ce projet de loi ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir trouver d'autres
formes d'action être créative dans la
nuit parce que le gouvernement de
l'autre côté semble déterminé à
continuer d'ailleurs le texte a débuté
son parcours législatif alors
l'intersyndicale se réunit en ce moment
donc je pense qu'elle va sortir avec l'
annonce d'une journée d'action
certainement la semaine prochaine nous
réfléchissons aussi à des actions
effectivement différente pour pouvoir
tenir dans la durée
beaucoup de choses sont débattus à
l'heure actuelle au niveau de la cgt
nous pensons lancer notre propre
conférence de financement de manière
très ouverte beaucoup plus ouverte que
le gouvernement pour montrer que les
propositions que nous faisons pour un
système de retraite solidaire et de haut
niveau pour tous il est possible il est
crédible et les finançable voilà
beaucoup de choses sont en discussion et
effectivement moi je suis effaré par
l'attitude du gouvernement qui dit
grosso modo on vient entendre le premier
ministre à l'assemblée je fais comme si
se passait rien continue
enfin quand même ils auraient pu au
moins pu être alertée par ce qu'a dit le
conseil d'état le conseil d'état c'est
pas rien quand conseil d'état dit que
l'étude d'impact
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une étude
d'impact pour un projet de loi c'est une
étude qui dit elles vont être les
conséquences du projet de loisir que ce
qu'est ce que ça va donner pour la vie
des gens et quand conseil d'état dit que
l'étude d'impact est lacunaire qu'elle
n'est pas suffisante qu'elle n'est pas
solide d'un point de vue juridique et
qu' elle critique le fait que 29
ordonnance vont être faites ce projet de
loi 29 s'était non plus au travail avec
jeanne 17 et 29 ordonnance ça veut dire
qu'ils vont avoir valeur de loi qui ne
rendons pas d'étude d'impact et le
conseil d'état note que c'est pour une
loi qui
agne auteurs inédite depuis 45
parce qu'elle remet en cause une partie
importante du contrat social des
français vous voyez ça c'est que c'est
quand même des choses qui devrait
alerter le gouvernement lui donner un
peu plus de modestie et pourrait voir en
live aux dernières effectivement maître
christian saint-palais vous alors sauf
erreur de ma part j'ai l'impression que
vous êtes une des seules professions
avec fonds de réserve très important
pour l'instant n'avoir pas obtenu gain
de cause à ce que le pouvoir de nuisance
n'a pas été assez grand avec vos grèves
ralentir les affaires on a vu les
danseurs les pompiers les pilotes les
navigants dans leur ensemble qu'ils ont
obtenu voilà des des aménagements c'est
toujours pas votre cas vous n'avez rien
obtenu pour l'instant même si on parlera
évidemment de la ministre qui a été
rassurante concernant les avocats ce
matin n'êtes peut-être obligé de les
croire
non je crois qu'elle a voulu être
rassurant de mais enfin personne n'est
dupe
si vous examinez un peu les messages sur
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde et
même très heurtée par ce discours qui
fait fi de toutes les objections que
nous avons formulées vous disiez tout à
l'heure que notre régime effectivement
disposer de réserves on leur a peut-être
tout à l'heure c'est une caisse autonome
ce n'est pas un régime spécial mais
gérée par les avocats qui le pilote et
en naviguant
nous avons notre régime autonome créée
par nous seuls pour la retraite de base
et la retraite complémentaire c'est ça
la grande spécificité de l'avocat qui le
nous nous avons déjà créé des conditions
d'égalité on dit aujourd'hui que l'on
veut créer l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes chez les avocats nous avons
déjà atteint cet objectif avec une
retraite minimum garantis quelles
qu'aient été les chaos dans la vie
professionnelle quelles qu'aient été les
heures de vie
les accidents de parcours 1450 euros
garantis le projet qu'on nous propose
aujourd'hui ses 1000 euros minimum dont
vous voyez nous allons y perd et nous
avons aussi parce qu'on peut se dire
mais vous voulez garder votre régime
autonome les avocats vous voulez rester
entre vous entre nom qui vous avez
cotisé et accumuler alors je conçois
consciente elle s'amuse le garder il y à
deux milliards en réalité de réserve
mais je veux dire quand même que ce
régime a été toujours solidaire du
régime général est que nous versons par
an 92 à 98 millions d'euros au régime
général c'est-à-dire par avocat et
parents 1250 euros
il faut pas croire et ou laisser dire
parce que c'est un peu l'image qu'ils
essaieraient d'entretenir que nous
serions de notre côté que nous voudrions
rester entre nantis alors que vous savez
et il faut le souligner que la
profession d'avocat revêt une diversité
tout à fait étonnante avec beaucoup de
confrères et consoeurs jeune ou pas
d'ailleurs qui ont un un revenu faible
un revenu tout à fait modeste et qui
donnent leur temps leur énergie leurs
compétences et leurs talents au service
des plus démunis de notre société sans
avoir des horaires très important lors
la ministre de la justice chez nos
confrères d'europe 1 ce matin vous
voulez est rassurante effectivement elle
a donné des exemples assez concret pour
un avocat qui gagnent autour de 32000
euros par an les pensions vont passer
selon elle de 2002 170 euros à 2500
euros par mois donc elle ne baisse pas
obbadi fonction ministre bra il faut
alors justement là nous sommes je crois
comme tous les citoyens français dans un
flou de chiens de mensonges de chiffres
vous savez il ya beaucoup de chiffres
qui ont été avancés avec celui que l'on
appelait l'avocat françois qui
démarrerait en première année à l'âge de
28 ans avait 46 mille euros et alors
vous verrez que partout les avocats
disent mais on cherche françois ceux qui
veulent se marier avec françois cherche
ce françois parce qu'il n'existe pas
c'est un cas utopique qui est présenté
pour nous faire croire que cette réforme
aurait des incidences extraordinaire
alors ce que je pense d'ailleurs c'est
que peut-être vous disiez tout à l'heure
mais vos actions sont elles suffisamment
nuisibles puisque c'est quand même ça
qu'il faut trouver un pouvoir d' alerte
en tout cas pour
est-ce qu'elles le sont suffisamment
quand on voit que rien ne bouge je pense
que nous avons un effort à faire nous
mêmes pour contredire les chiffres qui
sont avancés qui sont des chiffres faux
qui en tout cas ne sont pas étayées et
qui créent tous les avocats qui crée une
situation pour tous les avocats de
grandes inquiétudes
et c'est terrible d'être inquiet quand
je vois les jeunes et qui rentre dans la
profession et qui sont inquiets pour
l'avenir
on leur dit vous allez cotiser davantage
et nous ne pouvons pas cotiser davantage
c'est ça que ce qu'il faut comprendre
pour les avocats on leur dit vous avez
un prélèvement hauteur de 14 % de votre
revenu pour la retraite et désormais
vous allez passer à 28 parce que ça
c'est une réalité et nous avons un très
grand nombre de faits non quelle méthode
ni ce n'est pas un doublement puisque
nous allons baisser les cotisations aux
retraites elle parle précisément deux
fois 2 de cotisation mais elle pourrait
le voilà ce n'est pas un doublement
alors c'est un doublement dans le projet
initial est aujourd'hui puisque nous
disons et nous manifestons que nous ne
voulons pas ce qui ce qui a été prévu
par le gouvernement
alors aujourd'hui on nous dit mais on va
diminuer ailleurs on va diminuer pas
dans quelles conditions avec quelle
pérennité quelles garanties pour
l'avenir
rien bien sûr rien c'est pour ça que
nous disons les seydoux ne laissez nous
donc gérer notre système de recueil
comme nous avons su le faire vraiment je
vous assure que quand on vous dit il n'y
a pas d'étude d'impact suffisante c'est
le conseil d'état qui le dit c'est parce
que quand nous connaissons la situation
d'une profession nous voyons bien dans
ce qui est proposé que rien des chiffres
est rien et anticiper rien n'est
vraiment programmé rien et étayée dans
les promesses qui sont anne marie claire
cailletaud edouard fini par assurer au
sénat n'avoir pas peur du débat
parlementaire à l'assemblée au sénat
ceux qui disent que ce débat on a
entendu tout à l'heure de me prendre la
forme d'un champ de braise ne disent pas
quelque chose auquel je crois il promet
un vrai débat parlementaire on imagine
que vous n'avez plus confiance c'est
vrai que pour le moment le gouvernement
ne recule pas il ya la rue les
différentes professions il ya les
différents partis politiques les
parlementaires qui sont en fronde
vous avez clairement peur aujourd'hui
tous les deux d'ailleurs d'un passage en
force de l'exécutif
non mais c'est clair il a beau jeu de
dire qu'il n'a pas peur d'un débat
parlementaire mais je dire bon quand on
voit l'assemblée telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
effectivement moi moi je suis
franchement effrayé que des députés
soient prêtes à voter un texte alors
qu'il ya des trous dedans enfin c'est
quand même une première on sait la
majorité son père mais il se faire
exclure de leurs partisans mais d'accord
mais à un moment donné je trouve qu'il
faut être sérieux quand ils sont dix
représentants de la nation et qui sont
élus il ya des voix là et dont vous
attendez la république en marche alors
responsabilités bien sujet en donnant un
conseil d'état qui dit que l'étude
d'impact ne sécurise pas le texte
juridiquement juridiquement et quand
elle dit qu'en plus le fait d'avoir 29
ordonnance derrière 29 ordonnant se
donne pas de visibilité et que c'est un
texte extrêmement important parce qu'il
va modifier profondément contrat social
des français c'est quand même pas
possible que des députés acceptent
acceptent de voter un tel texte
parce qu'effectivement il a beau jeu de
dire ça va se passer on va passer en
force et dans deux mois dans trois mois
c'est plié
mais si si ça qu'il a dans la tête le
chambon le chante brel moi je ne
souhaite pas bien évidemment je le
souhaite pas mais il est responsable le
gouvernement actuel est responsable de
chant de braise quand il ya une majorité
de la population enfin ils ont la bouche
pleine du mot démocratie aujourd'hui
regardons quand même une majorité de la
population est contre ce projet de loi
une majorité d'organisations syndicales
qui replantent une majorité de saintes
de syndiqués et contre ce projet de loi
de salariés tu viens me donner la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement l'arrêt
lui c'est de dire je fais une pause je
fais une pause rameau projet les mâles
vont saleh ben voilà nous faisons plus
de pédagogie mais j'aime pas du tout ça
est au contraire ils font ce qu'il
continue à foncer et donc il ya quand
même un véritable moi je pense qu'ils
apprennent des vous lisiez alors que la
cgt allait faire sa propre
conférence de vie nancement on le sent
que la cgt philippe martinez en tout cas
va participer à la conférence de
financement qui s'ouvre vendredi avec
les autres syndicats c'est bien le cas
confirmés alors la conférence de
financement elle s'ouvre demain
oui la question et c'est que on sait pas
ce qu adam parce que si vous voulez pour
l'instant le ce qu'on sait c'est que ça
va être une réunion de trois heures de
14h30 à 17h30 ou le premier ministre on
va parler mais d'une part donc vous
c'est quand même visiblement une grosse
opération de communication
néanmoins la cgt sera présente elle n'a
jamais fait la chaise vide
donc elle sera présente mais si vous
voulez ce qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement pas prêt ministre c'est
qu'on avait un cadre extrêmement
contrainte dire qu'on rentre dans une
boîte et puis visiblement il ya qu une
porte de sortie c'est à dire qu'on peut
pas parler d'augmentation des
cotisations sociales ne peut pas parler
des exonérations de cotisations des
entreprises enfin voilà il ya beaucoup
de sujets qui sont à bout qui font que
de fait la sortie et les flécher sur
l'augmentation du temps de travail donc
il faut pas prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles non plus donc rentrer dans un
tel tunnel donc nous on va y aller
demain mais en fait vous demander le
retrait d'une ex donc c'est vrai que
vous m la marge de manoeuvre sera très
dominante on attendait la dernière et
non non non non parce que nous on venait
des propositions et donc demain on va
mettre sur la table nos propositions
parce que on dit oui il faut que le
système
il évolue pour prendre en compte tous
les nouveaux métiers pour prendre en
compte justement les carrières qui sont
h f il ya beaucoup de situations qui
doivent notre système doit être amélioré
et on a des propositions pour
l'améliorer et si on va les mettre à
table demain mais comment fait depuis
deux ans et malheureusement
visiblement on n'est pas du tout entendu
christian saint-palais vous attendez
quelque chose vous de cette conférence
de financement avec la cfdt est le seul
syndicat qui est assez d'accord avec ce
système universel à poser quand même ces
conditions avancées dans la justice
sociale pour donner du sens à cette
réforme avant de discuter de cet
équilibre des comptes
vous attendez quelque chose vous les
avocates de cette grande réunion demain
non nous sommes sur un sujet je dirais
plus circonscrit à notre profession mais
il ya de quoi être inquiet parce que
quand on entend nous allons gagner au
parlement c'est une équipe qui s'est
fait élire en disant nous allons changer
les pratiques gouvernementales les
pratiques de gouvernance les députés
godillots
on a connu c'est la cinquième république
alors ça ça n'est pas nouveau et ce qui
est vraiment très préoccupant c'est de
voir ces jeunes des députés jeudi jeunes
mais en tout cas en tant que député quel
que soit leur âge civile leur état civil
ces jeunes les députés qui rempile dans
des pratiques mais vraiment qu'ils ne
sont pas glorieuses et qui sont même
honteuse c'est à dire de nuire à
peut-être les ont signés pour la
république en marche c'est le même
emmanuel macron qui s'est fait élire
avait promis une réforme du système
universel à point alors voilà pas de
l'âge mais on vous dira peut-être mais
je sais qu'elle est le seul argument
mais vous savez parfaitement que dans le
projet présidentiel rien de ce qui est
aujourd'hui sur la table n'étaient
promis et aucun des électeurs n'a eu le
sentiment même les plus les plus proches
de ce programme
mais le principe de la bien sûr de la
retraite à points mais jamais par
exemple jamais aucun avocat qui a voté
pour la république en marche et il y en
eut beaucoup mais jamais aucun n'a
adhéré à un projet de réforme de la
retraite par exemple et donc ce qui est
très préoccupant c'est d'avoir le
sentiment que ça va être gouvernés de
force parce qu'on veut absolument avoir
comme skype c'est à dire il va falloir
montrer que l'on est capable d'avancer
ce que les autres gouvernements distille
n'ont pas su faire
et donc quand vous dites que demain
s'ouvre une
une opération des conférences de
financement mais oui nous sommes
inquiets parce qu'on se dit mais quels
sont les arguments qui vont être
entendus je crois que ce qu'ils savent
faire c'est techniquement mettre les
gens autour de la table et offrir des
postures des coupes des postures
physiques lors de la réunion syndicats
nous disent qu'il ya eu des vraies
négocier les avocats sont allés écouter
ce que le premier ministre avait à leur
dire ce week-end et ils sont ressortis
nos représentants sont ressortis en nous
disant mais enfin il ya eu un communiqué
du premier ministre et la présidente
christiane féral-schuhl du cnb qui est
donc notre organe représentatif a écrit
nous a écrit pour nous dire mais j'ai
l'impression que nous n'étions pas à la
même réunion
donc si vous voulez techniquement pour
l'image il y a de la concertation et sur
le fond il y a aussi une écoute pendant
la réunion j'ai assisté à des réunions
non pas sur la retraite mais sur
d'autres réunions sur la réforme des
lois sur la justice où on nous écoute et
parfois d'ailleurs nos interlocuteurs
sont de qualité mais ensuite on trace le
chemin qui avaient été fixés et rien ne
peut les faire dévier et surtout ici la
colère du peuple parce que c'est ça que
nous sommes nous sommes le peuple dans
la rue nous venons dire nous ne voulons
pas de ce que vous nous proposez et rien
n'y fait maître vous qui est par
définition un juriste la mise en garde
du conseil d'état avec ses quatre
groupes d'opposition qui ont demandé une
saisine du conseil constitutionnel aux
sujets de l'étude d'impact jugée
incomplète est insincère
est-ce que ça ça peut être une porte de
sortie crédibles endroit fait normaux
disais tout à l'heure
est-ce que alors que le débat
parlementaire s'ouvre est ce qu'on a des
raisons d'espérer quand même que être
entendu moi je crois à la force de
l'état de droit
oui il ne faut jamais désespérer
tailleur de l'état de droit le conseil
d'état a dit ce qu'il avait à dire
mais dans le cadre qui était le sien il
ne peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin
jamais sans doute n'est-il aller aussi
loin pour exprimer les critiques sur un
texte
alors il a dit ce qu'il avait à dire
mais il ne peut pas nous faire retirer
le texte ni la nuit nous ne sommes pas
là un jour le conseil constitutionnel
sera vraisemblablement saisie avant la
promulgation de la loi par des députés
les sénateurs 60 de parlementaire et
allons nous verrons lors je ne désespère
pas mais il faut encore que cette loi
viole un principe constitutionnel une
règle constitutionnelle savez il ya
aussi des draps et des retraits par
cuno ma question mais là nous verrons je
crois vraiment d'ailleurs les juristes
vont s'appliquer à proposer aux députés
les recours qu'il y aura lieu de faire
mais avant espérons que le travail
parlementaire a quand même une hausse de
4 du marie claire cailletaud pour finir
les prochaines actions justement vous
avez dit à une intersyndicale ce soit
mais que reste t'il effectivement si le
gouvernement devait rester sourd et muet
vos attentes
a tous je pense que toute façon la
colère elle continue donc elle est
vraiment très ancrée 1 franchement et
donc les gens vont trouver des formes de
mobilisation pour durer vous savez ils
sont très inventif dans les grèves ils
sont très très inventif il ya beaucoup
d'exemples qu on pourrait citer mais
donc je pense que les actions vont
continuer on a besoin d'eux ya eu des
méthodes jugées contestables de la part
de la cgt on en a déjà parlé ensemble
sur ce qu il ya encore eu beaucoup de
coupures aujourd'hui vous savez il ya eu
quand même 14 8 mégawatts qu'on attire
tiré sur le réseau aujourd'hui on se
rend pas compte parce que ça c'est pas
des coupures 1 mais c'est énorme c'est
énorme donc il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'action aujourd'hui encore et on va
continuer à avoir des actions donc on va
trouver je pense les salariés ils
veulent de toute façon ils sont
persuadés que ce projet est mauvais
parce que il va contribuer ce qu'ils
travaillent plus longtemps et qu'ils
aient moins la retraite donc de toute
façon moi je leur fais confiance ils
vont trouver des formes d'action pour
pouvoir continuer à exprimer leur
mécontentement lundi
tous les avocats sont appelés à
rejoindre paris lundi et je peux vous
dire que les bus et les trains sont déjà
plaints parce que les avocats veulent
absolument montrer d'abord que nous
sommes unis et que nous sommes
déterminés devons être on peut terminer
d'ailleurs il nous reste une minute
finalement on peut contester avec vous
et déterminer quelles vont être les
prochaines élections justement des
avocats est ce que vous allez continuer
effectivement a fait recette
cette grève qui bloque certaines tous
les jours les oreilles tous les jours
les avocats nous sollicitons les renvois
des affaires et les tribunaux jusqu'à
présent tu des oreilles assez attentive
à nos revendications mais maintenant ça
se crispe de plus en plus mais il ne
faut pas compter sur l'usure des avocats
c'est très compliqué de faire grève ça
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il faut
que nous expliquons d'abord aux juges
que nous ne voulons pas plaider à nos
clients qui attendent la résolution de
leurs litiges que nous ne voulons pas
plaider parce que nous faisons grève et
les avocats de ce ne perçoivent pas les
honoraires c'est difficile mais nous
sommes à ce point déterminé et je dirais
grâce à des mouvements parfois
enthousiaste quand on voit ce que fait
le barbour de bobigny via les confrères
et consoeurs qui sortent absolument je
dirais magique parce qu'il faut arriver
à redonner le moral à ceux qui sont
grévistes et il arriva le données dont
nous sommes déterminés et nous allons
commencer à faire gripper la machine ce
qu'on nous reproche parfois mais ce qui
est absolument indispensable et je
regrette que le gouvernement nous
conduisent à ces actions là je le
regrette je le déplore c'est très
douloureux pour nous de refuser de
plaider il ya des avocats qui jettent
leurs robes
vous ne savez pas ce que ça représente
c'est inné de tam hommes c'est forcément
une voie d d'ailleurs se réunir et vous
soyez d'accord les ss j'étais avocat
général pourquoi autant de secteurs qui
se mobilisent
merci en tout cas tous les deux marie
claire cailletaud donc de la cgt
christian saint-palais avocat d'être
venu avec nous pour parler de cette
réforme des retraites alors que la
conférence de financement s'ouvre demain
merci à vous dans quelques instants
restez avec nous nous recevrons notre
invité politique ce soir françois
asselineau président de l'union
populaire républicaine et puis nous
reviendrons sur le plan de paix au
proche orient ont dévoilé par donald
trump saluer paris freine mais rejeté en
masse par les palestiniens
[Musique]
quoi pour vous une république éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé quand il affiche
une opinion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et c'est sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place
et toi sanctionner les élus indélicats
et doit promouvoir au contraire ceux qui
proposent des mesures visant à éviter
les abus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne se sent pas protégés
c'était si terrible qu'on ne pouvait pas
dormir la nuit
[Musique]
nous vivions heures jusqu'à ce que la
violence soit venu frapper à notre porte
quand ils venaient ils pouvaient choisir
une femme à leur goût q la violer et
tuer son mari
il faisait tout ce qu'il voulait il se
croyait au dessus de la loi 7000 un
groupe d'hommes armés est entré chez moi
par effraction ils voulaient nous violer
moi et mes enfants
donc on était obligé de fuir j'ai fait
mes valises et je suis allé à carthagène
personne n'a réussi à m'en dissuader
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la place un personnel à chaque scène
de ce spectacle raconte l'histoire de
l'une de ces femmes l'histoire de la
souffrance que la violence sexuelle que
beaucoup d'entre elles entendues
réceptionner l'histoire de meurtres
jamais du fait d'être chassé de son
foyer d homicide et comment la dette
morale en gasoil est ce que ça
représente ici
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
si on chantait mais review bah tu dis
quoi
une chanson des augures si le psy moyer
claude berri crues yonne et yoli bi
envoyez vos paniers sont les nôtres
piquionne dalo guirassy
et biskra ya des coûts des vidéos de nos
geeks oda
un total de 40 à yala
à ceux-là je chante beaucoup aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française j -
2 avant le break site le divorce entre
londres et bruxelles sera officielle
vendredi à 23h mais c'est sans surprise
que les députés européens ont voté
aujourd'hui à une large majorité les
modalités du traité de retrait il
s'agissait de la dernière étape majeure
dans la ratification de l'accord trois 3
mois et demi après le référendum trois
ans et demi plus tard près de référendum
clément hospital aux côtés des drapeaux
10,28 limoux jack flottant corps au pied
du parlement européen les eurodéputés
britanniques n'en sont pas moins sur le
départ je suis très heureuse parce que
maintenant les gens vont vraiment voir
que nous avons franchi la première étape
nous avons techniquement quitter l'union
européenne et nous avons décidé cela il
ya déjà longtemps
donc c'est vraiment un soulagement dès
le 31 janvier le pays n'aura plus de
commissaire européen ni d'eurodéputés
plus de trois ans et demi après le
référendum
un point de non retour pour le chef de
file du bric site et opposant historique
à l'union européenne
nigel farrage le 31 janvier 2020 nous
quittons l'union européenne pour
franchir un point de non retour
c'est sa toute l'importance de cette
semaine pour ce qui est de ce que cela
signifie pour nous sur le plan
constitutionnel de notre place dans le
monde
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante depuis qu'henri 8 nous a fait
sortir de l'église de rome
il nous a fait sortir de l'église
romaine et le petit on le traité de rome
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible
mais alors à quoi ressemblera l'union
amputé d'un de ses états membres
la perte sera d'abord démographique
l'union européenne verra partir plus de
66 millions d'habitants soit près de 13
% de sa population et plus de 15% de son
pib
sans les britanniques les mieux passera
en deux
de la barre symbolique du demi milliard
d'habitants avec 446 millions de
personnes en son sein l'union perd
également un membre permanent au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu ainsi qu'une de ces
deux puissances nucléaires
le secrétaire britannique à la défense a
tout de même voulu rassurer ses
partenaires européens
le brésil ne remet en aucun cas en cause
des questions de sécurité de l'europe
qui est vraiment très important pour la
grande bretagne autant qu'elle l'est
pour l'état membre de l'union européenne
aura aucun problème et je pense que vous
savez que de relations bilatérales ont
été solides lorsque nous sommes dans
l'union européenne
ce sera tout aussi fort après l'union
européenne deux jours avant cette sortie
historique
c'est une journée chargée en émotion qui
attendent des britanniques
le parlement européen vote aujourd'hui
pour sceller le traité de divorce dès le
31 janvier à 23h le royaume uni rentre
dans une période de transition jusqu'à
la fin de l'année pendant laquelle ils
continueront d'appliquer les règles
européennes
un laps de temps pour négocier la
nouvelle relation qu'entretiendrait à
londres et bruxelles et à londres les
pêcheurs attendent le break site avec
impatience ils dénoncent les quotas qui
donne accès à leurs zones de pêche à
leurs homologues européens
ces derniers pêche six fois plus de
poissons dans les eaux britanniques que
les ressortissants du royaume uni dans
les eaux de l'union européenne le
gouvernement de boris johnson présente
ce soir un projet de loi destiné à
mettre fin à l'excès automatique des
navires européens l issue de la période
de transition le vote est prévu demain
le royaume uni devrait déterminer le
niveau d'accès des bateaux de l'union
européenne autorisée il ne devrait pas
être gratuit pour tous simplement parce
qu'ils sont là depuis des années et des
années
les règles ont changé et nous reprenons
le contrôle de nos propres ou décrypter
l'actualité nous sommes avec françois
céline et au président de l'union
populaire républicaine c'est notre
invité politique ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir françois asselineau merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
pacification c'est dur à dire sans
surprise ce soir vous vous enviez nos
amis britanniques à l'heure qu'il est
oui beaucoup beaucoup parce que c'est un
jour historique
le dernier obstacle sur le break 6 2
vient d'être levé à une écrasante
majorité au parlement européen et donc
le break si tu vas voir du vendredi le
31 janvier à minuit heure de paris je
les envie beaucoup parce que maintenant
ils peuvent reprendre leur politique une
politique conforme aux intérêts
nationaux conforme à ce que souhaite le
peuple britannique
je rappelle que boris johnson a fait
passer a décidé d'augmenter le smic de 6
2%
le smic britannique va désormais être
supérieurs au smic français ce qui est
interdit par les orientations le rapport
des grandes orientations des politiques
économiques fixés par la commission
européenne à la france qui exige depuis
des années que le smic n'augmente pas
plus vite que l'inflation même plutôt
moins
deuxièmement boris johnson a décidé
mettre le paquet sur le service de santé
25 milliards de livres sterling par an
et 15 28 milliard d'euros troisièmement
boris johnson a décidé que désormais la
politique en matière agricole sera
orienté vers une production bio une
production de produits d'agriculture
raisonnée
conformément à ce que souhaite le public
quatrièmement boris johnson a décidé de
re nationaliser une ligne de chemin de
fer allant de londres à l'écossé on
apprend aujourd'hui même qu'ils y avoir
de nouvelle compagnie d'autres
compagnies à un privé vous savez que
margaret thatcher avait privatisé des
chemins de fer qui vont être
renationalisée pour le défendre les
services publics ce que justement des
années des années d'ultralibéralisme
imposée par la commission européenne
avait anéanti par mois je constate que
c'est exactement ce que souhaiterait le
peuple français et donc je considère que
si nous nous sortons de l'union
européenne eh bien on pourrait répondre
à la crise des gilet jaune à la crise
des retraites vous savez que les
retraites sont exigés aussi la réforme
des retraites est exigé aussi par
l'union européenne mais françois sinon
on a l'impression que c'est d'un coup de
baguette magique on sortirait de
l'europe voilà tout s'arrangerait enfin
les caisses de l'état français en
l'occurrence ont tout de même vide vous
ouvrier où cet argent alors d'abord je
n'ai jamais dit que tous les problèmes
vont dépendre de l'europe dit que tout
serait réglé deux par balle un coup de
baguette magique mais néanmoins
d'essentiel seraient récupérés puisque
nous serions de nouveaux maîtres de
notre destin vous savez il ya eu
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit ça va être
terrible avec l'apocalypse et il n'y a
pas du tout d'apocalypse le fonds
monétaire international vient de révéler
qu'en fait toutes ces prévisions
apocalyptiques qui avait été fait
d'ailleurs du temps de madame christine
lagarde qui maintenant sévit à la bce
que toutes ces prévisions faites et et
fossiles qui aura pas d'apocalypse
premier point dieu ziem en moi j'avais
vu des articles de journaux des gens qui
disaient il faut absolument faire payer
aux britanniques il faut leur faire un
break site très très dur mais je
voudrais rappeler parce qu'à des gens
qui vont se poser la question à partir
du 1er février vers une négociation pour
avoir un accord de commerçants nouveau
le royaume uni et l'union européenne
alors certains disent va falloir payer
serait très bien il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux la france à chaque année
elle vend pour 32 milliards d'euros au
royaume-uni et l'achète pour 20
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire qu'on
dégage un excédent commercial de 12
milliards d'euros et en matière de
services ont dégagé un excédent en
matière de services de 6,7 milliards
d'euros ça veut dire que si la france
veut avoir une politique de sanctions de
l'union européenne à l'égard du royaume
uni celui ci peut très bien se venger
parce que vous savez normalement le
client est roi
et si vous savez que vous avez vu ce que
boris johnson a dit il est prêt à
augmenter terriblement les taxes sur le
champagne les produits français
si d'aventuré la france s'amuse à
socialement j'ajoute j'ajoute enfin en
plus que dans ce commerce extérieur
c'est vrai avec la france est vrai avec
l'animal il ya énormément d'échangés
inter entreprises sur les voitures
l'espace l'aéronautique et c'est donc en
fait personne
personne n'a intérêt à ce que le
président se passe mal et les français
vont d'un seul coup découvrir que tout
ce qu'on leur avait raconté et fo nous
sortir de l'union européenne ça n'est
pas se refermer sur le monde sait
reprendre des échanges normaux entre
puissances ayant par ailleurs leur
liberté leur politique nationale
peut-être que ça va abonder dans votre
sens mais enfin effectivement la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen
recruté britannique qui nous dit qu'ils
leur dis plutôt nous ne serons jamais
loin voilà en gros on vous aimera
toujours on sera là et vice versa ça
veut dire quoi
effectivement ça sent pas une rancune
après un divorce non consentie aux
élections vous savez ce que disait est
ce que disait le général entre dans les
relations internationales
il n'ya pas d'amitié il ya que des
intérêts si on là j'ai parlé du commerce
extérieur du commerce des services par
mois des investissements directs
il y à 3800 entreprises françaises qui
sont implantées aux états ou au royaume
uni et qui font un chiffre d'affaires de
l'ordre de 120 milliards d'euros par an
alors que dans l'autre sens il y à 1000
du jura 1200 entreprises britanniques
qui font un chiffre d'affaires de 34
milliard d'euros ça veut dire que en
matière d'investissements directs en
matière d'implantation comme en matière
commerciale comme en matière de services
la france a tout intérêt à faciliter la
signature d'un accord commercial avec le
royaume uni dont il ya eu des robots de
montagne mais vous voyez les
rodomontades on en parle le plus beau
c'est l'odeur et l'argent du beurre pour
les britanniques
la france les autres pays européens
peuvent y perd notamment les pêcheurs
français qui auront moins le droit
d'aller pêcher reçu chez les
britanniques vous êtes vous inquiet pour
vos compatriotes si bien sûr bien sûr je
pense que là aussi la france n'est pas
dénués d'arguments
donc je pense qu'il faudra trouver un
modus ville indique pour les pêcheurs
français et ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les britanniques reprennent le
pouvoir pour défendre les intérêts
nationaux britanniques mais nous on va
toujours on va on ne pourra toujours pas
défend des intérêts nationaux français
puisque sur cette affaire de pêcheurs on
ne sait pas nous qui définiront les
quotas de pêche et peut-être que les
britanniques seraient davantage
favorables à donner des quotas de pêche
à la france plutôt que des quotas de
pêche à la grèce ou à la pologne
on n'en sait rien deuxièmement moi ce
que je voudrais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que les les français de façon
générale je devrais défendre leurs
intérêts nationaux et en particulier en
matière budgétaire
le départ du royaume uni va faire un
trou dans la caisse de l'ordre de 10 à
14 milliards d'euros
il va falloir le comble et qui est ce
vrai qui va me payer les pays
contributeurs nets
l'allemagne et la france ça veut dire
que la france va être taxé de plusieurs
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
à la place des britanniques et tout ça
pour quoi pour aller financer des
infrastructures dans les pays de l'est
pour aller donner de l'argent à
l'ukraine ou à la turquie alors que nous
nous avons nous sommes dans une
situation dramatique budgétairement vous
le disiez tout à l'heure alors sortir de
l'union européenne s'est récupéré une
marge de manoeuvre budgétaires
considérables 10 milliards d'euros tout
de suite puisque nous dépensons 10
milliards d'euros de plus que ce que
nous recevons de l'union européenne et à
terme sortir de l'union européenne c'est
ne pas se substituer au manque à gagner
britannique alors les dépenser dans
l'autre sens aussi un puisque selon une
étude de bloomberg economics la facture
de break site atteindra les 200
milliards de livres
145 milliards d'euros un peu plus d'ici
la fin de l'année la procédure de sortie
de l'union européenne aura coûté presque
autant que le montant total que le
royaume uni a versé au budget européen
au cours des 47 dernières années ça vous
inspire quoi vous le progrès le site
je savais que c'était une fake news que
c'est du pipeau que tout sa bouille que
tout ça est fondé sur des hypothèses de
croissance complètement démentiel et je
cette info c'est un faux comme il y
avait eu des faux sondages
ça fait partie toujours là mais ni sur
le project faire peur aux gens
non la réalité c'est que la zone euro
est la zone de plus faible croissance
mondiale et que le royaume uni n'étant
d'ailleurs pas dans la zone euro avait
quand même été affectés par cette faible
que le faible dynamisme l'union
européenne de façon générale est une
espèce de poids mort qui pèsent sur les
économies des pays de l'union européenne
le royaume uni on va voir vous savez pas
ce qu'il va se passer on va voir ce qui
va se passer
et pour nous c'est un formidable comment
dirais-je test grandeur nature pour la
première fois un grand pays de l'union
européenne sort de l'union européenne et
on va maintenant pouvoir voir les
français vont pouvoir constater ce qui
se passe pour de bon j'invite d'ailleurs
on organise une grande fête si vous me
le permettez vendredi soir à paris 23
rue basfroi paris 11e
de 20h à 1h du matin on va avoir
d'ailleurs de nombreux responsables
politiques beaucoup de journalistes qui
vont venir également des anglais des
messages de ministre britannique
pour fêter ce break si tu sais tu ne ce
n'est pas une soirée huppert c'est une
soirée philippe le brech site
eh bien je n'invite ce qui me regarde
s'ils veulent venir assez ça déjà qu'il
ya beaucoup de demandes de primes et
beaucoup beaucoup de médias dans
l'actualité
nationale c'est évidemment toujours
dominé par la réforme des retraites ce
huitième journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui moins de monde dans la rue
mais on sait voilà par les sondages
effectivement qu'une écrasante majorité
de français est toujours contre cette
réforme avec désormais une fronde
parlementaire après notamment les
remarques du conseil d'état le
gouvernement qui semble persister et
signer une réaction une explication
écoutez moi je les dires dit monsieur
macron devrait arrêter les frais le
gouvernement plus un seul ministre ne
peut sortir sans être course et
d'ailleurs les députés en marche même se
terre tellement ils ont peur d'être
course et moi j'veux plus elle nous
participons lui père participe à des
élections municipales
je vois que tu rentres dans un certain
nombre de deux circonscriptions tadmiri
les candidats de en marche n'ose même
pas dire qu'ils sont en match ils ont
honte de leur étiquette voilà où l'on en
est on a paraît-il une vidéo qui a été
saisie vous savez au théâtre des bouffes
du nord où on voyait un monsieur macron
avec madame trognee son épouse paraît-il
courir comme des dératés devant la peur
que d'être arrêté par la foule
on est dans une situation ubuesque ça ça
vous inspire quoi tout de même samedi le
coup de gueule de robert badinter chez
chez nos confrères je ne sais plus c'est
vrai que ça ne porte pas tout même en
tant que démocrate
ce genre de scène est ce qu on est
obligé d'abord j'ai été surpris que
monsieur badinter ne s'émeuvent pas non
plus des personnes qui sont éborgné
mutilé etc
je suis surpris que monsieur badinter
nous appellent à la démocratie mais la
démocratie c'est quoi au bout du compte
c'est au peuple français d'obéir à
monsieur maquereau ou à monsieur macron
d'obéir au peuple français
tous les sondages montrent que 70% des
français sont contre il veut imposer
cette réforme parce qu'il a le pistolet
sur la tempe de la commission européenne
je rappelle que la réforme des retraites
est demandée par le rapport annuel des
grandes orientations des politiques
économiques et ceci depuis longtemps je
rappelle que beaucoup de français
commencent à comprendre que cette
retraite dite universelle qui d'ailleurs
n'est plus universel parce qu'ils sont
c'est dès maintenant c'est les sapeurs
pompiers avant c'était
policiers et c'est donc en fait ce qui
d'ailleurs c'était si génial que ça
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement cède
sur les différentes catégories
socioprofessionnelles
en réalité il s'agit d'avoir une
retraite prétendument universel mais en
fait par points dont l'objectif est
d'apporter rire les retraités pour
pousser les plus aisés qui d'ailleurs ne
cotiseront plus au dessus d'un certain
montant pour pousser les plus aisés à
faire de la retraite par des confusions
parce qu'au-delà d'un certain revenu
apparemment il y a plus de cotisations
donc là aussi à toutes confessions
écouter les français ne veulent pas de
cette réforme
ça ce sont ces détails selon les
sondages
le conseil d'état a fait c'est une
institution extrêmement police et 1c
nous sommes au milieu de la route
fonction publique avec des gens qui sont
d'une très grande urbanité et d'une
urbanité exquise
il le conseil d'état fait à des
importuns comme apporter au gouvernement
une réponse comme on a très rarement vu
dans la république
en gros c'est ni fait ni à faire le
budget le projet n'est absolument pas
financer n'est pas bouclé on est dans
une espèce d'impréparation général et
tout ça dans un espèce de chaos social
qui ne fait que s'aggraver
je suis allé sur le terrain d'ailleurs
et hier il y avait en bas de chez moi
la la la la manifestation des pompiers
la situation est en train de virer au
chaos
monsieur macron doit retirer cette
réforme et s'il ne le fait pas eh bien
nous lorsque nous serons arrivés au
pouvoir nous reviendrons au système
antérieur une dernière petite question
puisqu'on arrive à la fin de cette
interview qui d'après vous parmi ces
personnalités ferait un meilleur roi moi
mon président qu emmanuel macron cet
intitulé
c'est un sondage ipsos pour le point 23
personnalités
vous n'êtes pas dedans alors que vous
aviez eu les paré d'argent ça vu
concourir à la dernière élection
présidentielle
vous nous expliquer comment je
l'expliqué par le fait que les instituts
de sondage systématiquement font comme
si le père n'existait pas nous avons des
nombreux témoignages d'adhérents
écoutez je sais que je ne sais pas
comment le qualifier mais c'est un fait
que les instituts de sondages font comme
si nous n'existions pas d'ailleurs à
part rt france épée qui sud radio
nous avons les plus grandes difficultés
a même passé dans les médias est ce que
vous trouvez normal
exemple alors que tout le monde sait qu
ont certains m'appellent monsieur fréq
site que j'ai créé le parti du fric site
que depuis bientôt treize ans je milite
pour le fric site est ce que vous
trouvez normal que depuis les élections
présidentielles je n'ai jamais été
invité sur tf1
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
depuis les élections européennes je n'ai
jamais été invité sur france 2 qui est
payé par les contribuables
c'est à dire que nous avons 1,2 pour
cent des français qui ont voté pour
l'upm
normalement nous devrions passer
régulièrement ne serait ce que parce que
nous finançons le service public de
l'audiovisuel
nous ne sommes jamais invités et ce sont
les instituts de sondage qui le font je
donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui nous
suivent sur rupert tv huppert tv sur
youtube nouvelle salon de records en
records puisque on va franchir bientôt
les 130 mille abonnés et puis notre si
tu perds point fr qui le site le plus
consulté de tous les partis politiques
français
c'est la revanche du bouche à oreille et
d'internet contre le verrouillage des
médias et des instituts de sondage merci
françois cellino d'avoir été avec nous
après washington hier moscou aujourd'hui
et demain benyamin nétanyahou va plaider
en faveur du plan de paix de donald
trump pour le moyen-orient le premier
ministre israélien doit rencontrer
vladimir poutine alors que le texte est
rejeté par l'autorité palestinienne
grégoire dos est annoncée depuis des
mois le plan de paix américain a été
dévoilé ce mardi en grande pompe avec
une absence notable celle de la
palestine l'une des deux parties
concernées donald trump et benyamin
nétanyahou main dans la main ont
présenté un plan qualifié d' accord du
siècle par le président américain
un projet confié au printemps 2017 au
gendre et conseiller du locataire de la
maison blanche
jared kushner un des points les plus
sensibles de ce document déjà
controversé la reconnaissance par les
états unis de la souveraineté d'israël
sur les colonies dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés
le président américain a également
précisé que jérusalem restera la
capitale indivisible d'israël
la partie est de la ville est seulement
suggéré par washington pour devenir la
capitale d'un éventuel état palestinien
en état qui verrait le jour sous
conditions parmi lesquelles un rejet
clair du terrorisme trump et
enthousiaste au moment de parler de ce
nouveau plan de paix ma vision présence
une occasion gagnant gagnant pour les
deux parties une solution réaliste à
deux états qui résout le risque que
représente un état palestinien pour la
sécurité d'israël
aujourd'hui israël fait un grand pas
vers la paix le premier ministre
israélien s'est lui aussi grandement
félicité de cet accord
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020 car ce jour là vous êtes
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître la souveraineté d'israël sur
des zones comme la judée samarie qui
sont vitales pour notre sécurité et qui
sont au coeur de notre patrimoine
côté palestinien les réactions sont aux
antipodes
malgré des désaccords récurrents avec le
fatah le hamas s'est joint la réunion
d'urgence programmée hier par le
président mahmoud abbas ce dernier a
rejeté en bloc cet accord je veux dire
aux deux trump et netanyahu que
jérusalem n'est pas à vendre
que tous nos droits ne sont pas à vendre
ni à négocier et que votre accord de
conspiration ne passera pas la colère
s'est aussi exprimée dans les rues
palestiniennes
à la suite de l'annoncé commune de
donald trump et benyamin nétanyahou les
manifestants ont témoigné de leur
opposition au projet porté par
washington
s'estimant perdant sur toute la ligne
un plan qui en définitive peu de chance
de connaître un meilleur sort que les
précédentes tentatives américaines et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis pelé mousse avec patrick manning
scène expert en relations
internationales c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir patrick hansen merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt français d'avoir
patienté l'armée israélienne annonce ce
soir renforcer sa présence en
cisjordanie près de la bande de gaza
avec des troupes de combat c'était déjà
le cas quelques jours avant dans la
vallée du jourdain est ce que le plan
est déjà finalement mis en oeuvre avant
même d'être acceptée on l'a vu
d'ailleurs rejetée par les palestiniens
grâce à une faute je pense qu'ils sont
déjà en train de l'appliquer moche il
était déjà en oeuvre depuis plusieurs
années
c'est cette une politique israélienne
mais né sous les radars une politique
n'y ont déclaré des objectifs qui m'ont
déclaré qu'israël connaissait bien je te
dis que les palestiniens je connaissais
bien mais qui avait échappé
tout est resté invisible la visite pour
le reste du monde pour les journaux et
pour washington où on ne parle pas de ce
genre de choses
les palestiniens savent bien que c'est
pourri tickets sont en cours depuis des
décennies maintenant et même au cours du
processus de paix d'oslo pour detroit de
la poudre aux yeux
c'est au sto 2.0 rousseau relance ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 90 ont
depuis l'année 2000 accord en fin de
compte
reese à être rejetée par les
palestiniens
ce qu'ils ont déjà fait auparavant
israël et les états unis au rheu la
murray les palestiniens pour leur rejet
via l'accord totalement acceptable pour
washington
alors donné hier en tout cas à inventer
son super d'ilan en exhortant les
palestiniens à l'accepter
leur disons pas c'est votre seule chance
d'avoir un état indépendant est ce qu'il
faut croire une partie de son discours
au moins les palestiniens peuvent ils y
croire selon vous sionistes ce n'est pas
un accord c'est un jeudi matin pour les
palestiniens
accepter cela c'est votre dernière
chance
limoux veuille brasserie l'annexion de
la cisjordanie est en cours de manière
très agressive et il y aura sans doute
demain avoir de la knesset pour annexer
30 % de la cisjordanie supplémentaires
cela suit les méthodes des états unis
s'agissant de nouveau appel aux
terralies ce moment on rêve du général
afin de décrédibiliser des résolutions
de ruches cela s'applique tout à fait à
cette situation
move s'est montré très agressif dans la
colonisation des territoires occupés ou
des territoires controversé que quelques
étés les résolutions adoptées à
l'international processus d'oslo et
maigreux colonisateur s'installer en
dotant ses régions sous les radars
cela a changé la situation sur le
terrain et cela va continuer de la sorte
parce qu'il ya des négociations
difficiles au niveau international
38 ans la situation continue d'évoluer
sur le terrain israël
on commence tous les territoires occupés
sur le plateau du golan et en
cisjordanie ou dans la vallée du
jourdain santé valais et ils vont
continuer quels que soient les besoins
et les demandes des palestiniens leur
demande d'accepter une solution à deux
états alors que tous les experts tous
lui roger comment veux-tu facteurs je ne
prenne bien que la solution à deux états
je n'ai aucune arnaque on va gagner du
temps de jeu et cela depuis la lettre g
déverser des négociations la solution
des états déjà morte
ils disent que peut-être à venir il
pourrait avoir un état mais vous devez
moi je veux dire au pays à toutes ces
demandes ce n'est pas ça un accord c'est
un ultimatum
merci beaucoup et patrick hansen ne nous
avoir apporté en tout cas votre point de
vue en direct sur arte france dans vu de
l'extérieur ce soir dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous
reviendrons sur la 8e journée de grèves
et de manifestations contre la réforme
des retraites le débat parlementaire est
attendu malgré l'avis critique du
conseil d'état et puis nous partirons en
belgique qui n'a pas de gouvernement
depuis plus d'un an maintenant
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de clips de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation des fruits est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
j'ai fort potentiel programme moi et je
ferai que ce que tu veux toi tu es un
robot mimoun et des viennes être humain
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
je
hu l'air des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre de
communiqué en fait ils vont changer
notre vie
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
on à construire
attention attention la tête mais qu'est
ce qui fait que nous allons découvrir le
meilleur de kertch on a construit ça
doit être bon
attention web or on a construit et le
bon tu le vois oui il est en
construction on la construit avec six
mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
heures d'émission en direct sur rt
france tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi
tout aussi déterminé mais moins nombreux
dans les rues pour cette huitième
journée de mobilisation
interprofessionnelle aujourd'hui contre
le projet de réforme des retraites qui a
commencé son parcours législatif
à la veille de l'ouverture de la
conférence sur le financement la cfdt
seul grand syndicat soutenir un système
universel réclament des avancées
sociales
[Musique]
la belgique privée de gouvernement
depuis plus d'un an une situation loin
d'être inédit pour le plat pays c'est
des affaires courantes sont traités il
n'y a ni budget voté ni politique engagé
une impasse politique qui fait resurgir
l'hypothèse d'un référendum sur la
partition du pays
l'accord sur le break site ratifier une
large majorité par le parlement européen
le grand saut est imminent le
royaume-uni quittera l'europe ce
vendredi viendront ensuite les
négociations sur sa future relation avec
les 27
le plus dur est devant nous avertit
paris mais non
ne seront jamais loin promet quand elle
la présidence de la commission
européenne
[Musique]
huitième jour de mobilisation nationale
interprofessionnelle contre la réforme
des retraites manifestations région et
dans la capitale à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats la cgt fo grant est leur
objectif le retrait du texte adopté
vendredi en conseil des ministres le
cortège parisien est arrivé place vauban
aux invalides
à noter très interpellation à 16h15
selon la préfecture de police nous
concerne directement parce que si la
réforme passe demain en fait c'est nos
cotisations qui vont pas augmenter mais
doublé et qui vont simplement faire
mourir d'un cabinet des cabinets comme
les nôtres mais donc sa composante 50%
des gens qui exercent ce métier on pense
dans cette réforme à toute la fonction
publique c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est
là aujourd'hui
la disparition du statut d'actif c'est
une catastrophe pour ce qu'ils possèdent
et déjà c'est aussi une mauvaise
nouvelle pour nous qu'il demande y ont
déjà depuis dix ans c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les collègues de la
fonction hospitalière pour les égoutiers
on suit l'actualité des autres en suit
l'actualité des avocats on comprend leur
système de retraite ont fait l'effort de
comprendre les autres professions parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui joue c'est
l'avenir de tout le monde accepté de
diviser les personnels accepter que la
retraite du privé du public baisse a
accepté de mettre à mal la sécu dans ce
pays la sécurité sociale parce que c'est
ça qui vont s'attaquer ensuite non cette
réforme elle est mauvaise elle casse
ddd zaki qu'on a obtenu plus des années
le système fonctionne
on veut bien rediscuter du système pour
l'améliorer mais on veut surtout pas ce
cette case organisé qui va forcément
vous tirez tuque les retraites vers le
bas on est là pour faire valoriser nos
droits à la retraite
à savoir qu'un négligé pour faire sa mue
il a 58 ans reste d'espérance de vie
et actuellement il part à 52 ans pour
boire
réputé un petit coup d'arrêt avec la
modification des catégories actives la
prochaine conclure prochain à jamais
retraite à 62 ans
donc on a deux c'est pour ça qu'ils
étaient derrière moi mais aussi pour
faire vraiment là bas mais se faire
entendre en contestation dans la rue
mais également à l'assemblée nationale
si le conseil d'état se montre critique
quatre groupes d'opposition demandent
une saisine du conseil constitutionnel
aux sujets de l'étude d'impact du g1
complète
le pcf a présenté un contre projet
prévoit y lire en âge de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans les républicains eux
demandent 20 nouveaux textes et
dénoncent la précipitation et de
l'amateurisme du gouvernement l'exécutif
qui appelle au calme le premier ministre
edward flip dit ne pas avoir peur du
champ devrait un élément à l'opposition
je n'ai pas peur du débat parlementaire
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat ce
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils disent que ce
débat devrait prendre la forme d'un
champ de braise ne disent pas quelque
chose auquel je crois
nous allons tenir le calendrier que nous
nous sommes fixés monsieur le président
marseille et le calendrier que nous
avons fixée c'est effectivement la
présentation d'un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres c'était vendredi
dernier et l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale puis par le sénat au cours du
premier semestre de ce texte de façon à
ce que nous puissions espérer
je ne veux pas préjuger de l'issue du
débat parlementaire mais c'est en tout
cas l'objectif que nous nous fixons une
adoption du texte avant l'interruption
estivale et pour en parler nous sommes
avec boris délégué cgt alstom élus pcf
front de gauche avant bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france abordé des manifestants toujours
très déterminés mais moins nombreux
clairement
la rue on imagine que ça devient
compliqué pour les salariés de se
libérer très régulièrement pour aller
manifester comment vous expliquer en
tout cas cette baisse peut être de
fréquentation dans la rue alors que les
sondages montrent toujours que les
français sont en grande majorité contre
cette réforme
alors aujourd'hui effectivement c'était
une journée de mobilisation plus réduite
je vais vous le dire on le savait avant
est ce que dans notre organisation des
manifestations il ya des des jours de
mobilisation plus importante et d'autres
plus réduite donc on savait aujourd'hui
que ce serait une mobilisation plus
faible
ceci dit on jetait dans la manifestation
aujourd'hui il y avait beaucoup de monde
il y avait beaucoup de monde il y avait
des salariés de plaintes syndicat avait
aussi beaucoup de personnes qui ne sont
pas syndiqués et qui bat son sont là
pour défendre le notre système de
retraites et dépenses jusqu'au bout que
enfin cela réformes promises
enfin misant pas là que le gouvernement
ne veut mettre en place et néfaste et
sera néfaste pour l'énorme majorité des
salariés donc les mobilisations dans les
entreprises effectivement c'est yahia
pas mal de jours de grève
donc aujourd'hui dans mon entreprise il
ya eu effectivement moins de grévistes -
de manifestants peu d'autres jours
cependant les salariés
lorsqu'on leur parle tous les jours avec
eux sont de plus en plus conscient que
la réforme promise par enfin que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place
nm et mauvaises qui vont se faire avoir
ils vont se faire rouler parce que les
cotisations vont réduire le durée de
travail va s'allonger
on sait moi dans mon entreprise c'est
essentiellement une entreprise
d'ingénieurs et cadres on est à 60 %
d'ingénieurs et cadres
ce que veut nous mettre en place le
gouvernement sait travailler jusqu'à
minimum 67 68 ans voilà puissant si on
prend des personnes qui ont fait des
études jusqu'à bac + 5
on rajoute les 43 42 années de
cotisation minimum pour avoir une
retraite qui sera sur des valeurs assez
basse on arrive à 67 ans à 67 ans est ce
qu'on est encore en mesure de travailler
aussi bien dans un bureau d'études
je ne le pense pas et d'autre part en
fait on a autre chose à faire à 67 ans
on a à avoir une retraite bien méritée
aujourd'hui justement cette baisse de la
mobilisation en tout cas dans la rue est
ce que vous ne craignez pas que d'un
point de vue évidemment du gouvernement
et bien on soit tenté de passer en force
et ce lien ben voilà on montre à
l'opinion publique que le mouvement se
tasse et puis on y va on est légitime
est ce que vous n'avez pas cette crainte
là bas c'est pas une crainte c'est
effectivement le gouvernement et sur
cette stratégie comme il a déjà eu cette
stratégie sur d'autres mouvements
précédemment pendant la loi travail
comme et si on revient plus auparavant
comme du temps des certaine mobilisation
sous françois hollande comme certaine
mobilisation sous jacques chirac
la cpe sur la loi cpe s'avérer aussi
cette chose là et donc les gouvernements
jouent à dire que la mobilisation baisse
il ya tout le temps - de manifestants -
de ma fille de niffer ce nom soit disant
enfin bon à la fin aujourd'hui on
n'était pas deux arbres dans la
manifestation on était quand même un
certain nombre donc voilà c'est une
stratégie absolument classique
la question essentielle effectivement
c'est celle du rapport de force le
gouvernement veut faire croire
effectivement que le rapport de force et
est en diminution
ce qu'on constate c'est que dans les
entreprises
le rapport de force il reste quand même
équivalent les salariés sont de plus en
plus conscients et c'est l'intérêt je
dirais même de la la longueur de ce
mouvement c'est que de plus en plus de
salariés se rendent compte des problèmes
nous à la cgt dans mon entreprise par
exemple on fait des hommes d'information
au début il ya que quelques salariés qui
sont au courant
nous voilà c'est loin toute façon dans
les médias on nous en parle peu des
détails et aujourd'hui on en parle de
plus en plus maintenant qu'on est à deux
mois trois mois jusqu'en plication avez
vous les
les chiffres exacts parce que ce qui
domine justement c'est cette confusion
c'est que personne n'a l'air de me
semblait savoir à quelle sauce il va
être mangé et dont la méfiance
d'ailleurs vous ça y est vous commencez
à y voir très clair
alors disons que l'incertitude c'est
justement une des une des choses
problématique alors dans l'incertitude
en fait parce que ce que le gouvernement
va mettre en place et une retraite
tombola c'est à dire on sait parce qu'on
va avoir le point on sait le point de ma
question va ne sera pas fixée donc on ne
sait pas combien vaudra le point
cependant il ya des paramètres globaux
qui sont présents dans là dans le projet
du gouvernement qui vont amener à une
baisse du point on ne sait pas
exactement dire à combien elle mais
lorsque dans la loi il écrit que la
valeur maximum pour le budget des
retraites doit être de 14% du pib
sachant que le nombre de retraités va de
manière globale dans les prochaines
années augmenter et qu'aujourd'hui on
est à ont consommé 13 8% du pib pour les
retraites ça veut dire qu'il nous reste
que une marge absolument minimum pour
prendre beaucoup de retraités en plus
est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
intrinsèquement que la valeur du point
va baisser
si on prend un bon exemple justement
c'est la suède ou le modèle par points a
été mis en place depuis un certain
nombre d'années
aujourd'hui pour un travailleur moyen
pourra toucher autant qu'avant la mise
en place du système par points
il doit travailler jusqu'à 75 ans pour
avoir la même pension ça c'est le
chiffre actuel
en suède il ya d'autres paramètres qui
sont par contre que fixé dans le projet
du gouvernement
c'est par exemple la réduction du
plafond de cotisation
ça c'est quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu
abscons parfois mais dans une entreprise
comme la mienne c'est très précis c'est
à dire que tous les hauts salariés ceux
qui ont des salaires à 10000 euros par
mois dans mon entreprise il ya salariés
qui ont qui touchent dix mille euros
brut par mois environ 200 en france
eh bien ces personnes-là coup tu n'as
arrêterons et l'entreprise arrêtera de
cotiser à partir d'une valeur beaucoup
plus basse à la louche
les entreprises vont économiser entre
3,7 et 4 milliards d'euros par an sur
ces hauts salaires qui ne se cotiseront
plus et ça c'est quelque chose qui est à
peu prêt chiffré qui est très précis ça
fera des cotisations en moins et donc
forcément moins de valeur alors aussi
quelque chose par rapport à ça c'est que
dans notre le gouvernement veut dire
qu'il veut faire un système unique de
retraite
je peux vous dire c'est faux et dans mon
entreprise on a mis en place lanto de la
direction a mis en place un second
système de retraite parallèle
ça s'appelle la retraite supplémentaire
c'est à dire c'est une cotisation à par
une laisse malheureusement à ce qu'on
ait des avancées chez nous n'ont
absolument rien manque chez nous c'est
un fonds de pension i qui sera géré par
amundi qui est un concurrent de
blackrock
c'est un fonds de pension boursiers
gérer donc par chez nous à amundi il ya
blackrock se sont il ya quelques grands
groupes qui font ça quelques uns sont
français beaucoup sont américains c'est
donc la retraite supplémentaire qui est
alors chez moi dans mon entreprise
les ouvriers ne cote ne sont pas dedans
les employés ne sont pas dedans
les techniciens ne sont pas dedans les
ingénieurs cotisent un petit peu et par
contre les grands salaires à 10000 euros
15000 euros par mois cotisent beaucoup
l'entreprise met beaucoup d'argent pour
pour un salaire de dix mille euros
à la louche l'entreprise mais 2500 euros
par an dans ce fonds
c est donc c'est là où en fait on va
parce qu'en fait c'est la loi a été mise
en place il ya quelques temps ça
s'appelle la loi enfin l'article 83 qui
permet d'introduire de manière
obligatoire les fonds de pension dans
les entreprises et donc la visée du
medef depuis un certain un certain non
c'est clairement de baisser la retraite
habituelle
et de monter les fonds de pension merci
en tout cas pour ces explications
techniques mais utile merci monsieur
morose d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rtl révèle un grand plaisir
merci cela fait maintenant plus d'un an
que la belgique est sans véritable
gouvernement 407 jours précisément
comment le pays en est arrivé là quelles
sont les conséquences d'une telle
situation
reportage à bruxelles des selles farges
avec renault parquet un gouvernement
officiel presse qu'un vague souvenir
pour les belges depuis la démission du
premier ministre charles michel le 18
décembre 2018
la belgique est dirigée par un
gouvernement d'affaires courantes dont
les compétences sont limitées
ce contexte n'est pas étranger au belge
en 2010 et 2011 déjà l'absence de
gouvernement dans le pays avait duré
cinq cent quarante et un jours
alors aujourd'hui c'est avec résilience
qu'ils prennent la situation
je pense qu'à un moment oui ils vont ils
vont quand même trouvé trouvé un conte
premier ça prendra encore du temps pour
l'accepter situation j'espère quand même
que ça va se débloquer mais dans le
quotidien en tout cas j'ai envie de la
vie quotidienne tous les journées on est
assez peu impacté on a déjà vécu cette
situation et c'est toujours la même
chose c'est avec souvent la nva et puis
les autres partis socialistes qui ne
veulent pas former de gouvernement avec
la nva
il ya beaucoup de gens qui parlent de de
la formation du gouvernement mais la vie
selon l'accord donc l'impasse politique
dans laquelle se trouve le pays est en
partie due à la fracture entre le nord
du territoire
une flandre très à droite et le sud la
wallonie qui elles votent
majoritairement à bouche
à cela s'ajoutent des mésententes entre
des partis comme le ps et le nva
incapable de former un gouvernement
mais pour ces élus l'issue de cette
crise politique que vit la belgique
passe forcément par une coalition
il faut maintenant que les personnes
veuillent bien vraiment se mettre autour
de la table on n'en est pas encore là on
est toujours au stade d'informations
avec certains partis clés de la venue de
pays qui bloque
et donc maintenant on voudrait que
chacun puisse venir autour de la table
avec un peu de bonne volonté et trouver
vraiment des solutions
la belgique est dans une impasse qui est
du jamais vu inédit vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui à notre niveau le fédéral
doit trouver 12 milliards de moyens
budgétaires 12 milliards d'euros et les
entités du sud sont elles mêmes en
difficulté de l'ordre de 2 milliards ce
qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on a une
triple crise financière institutionnelle
et politique
parmi les autres pistes possibles un
retour aux urnes mais selon certains
députés
le fossé entre le nord et le sud
pourrait se creuser encore un peu plus
alors peut-on envisager un retour aux
urnes pour les beiges le pays peut-il
continuer son gouvernement encore
longtemps éléments de réponse avec dave
sinardet professeur de sciences
politiques
alors je me suis arrêté parce que vu -
exclu cependant il faut une majorité à
la chambre des représentants pour
organiser de nouvelles élections et
beaucoup de partis craignent ces
nouvelles élections parce que déjà en
mai dernier ils ont donc tous perdu ces
élections tous les partis qui ont
gouverné
bon entre temps donc ils n'ont pas été
capables de former un nouveau
gouvernement dont on peut s'imaginer que
la plupart d'entre eux
perdre encore plus les élections qui
seraient potentiellement organisé il ya
le problème du budget le budget qui l'a
kiki qui est de plus en plus en déroute
en belgique donc si on ne prend pas
d'initiatives ça va s'empirer
il ya beaucoup aussi beaucoup d'autres
défis socio économique climatique de
mobilité et autres grands problèmes qui
peuvent pas être adressées par ce
gouvernement puisqu'il puisqu'il n'est
pas là c'est des choses qui vont quand
même sur le long terme probablement se
faire sentir mais pour en parler nous
sommes avec un david leicester vice
président du mouvement réformateur brecé
droit candidat à la présidence bonsoir
des visiteurs merci d'être avec nous
donc depuis décembre 2018 que la
belgique n'a pas de gouvernement et vu
de l'extérieur vous de la france on a un
finalement l'impression que cette
situation n'affecte pas tellement le
quotidien des beiges
est ce que c'est le cas où on se trompe
de loin reste chez situation temporaire
c'est vrai que pour le moment dans la
vie de tous les jours des belges on ne
le sent pas il faut le reconnaître
cela dit le jour où on aura enfin au
gouvernement une série de mesures vont
devoir être prises parce que vous l'avez
entendu lors du reportage précédent
pendant tout ce moment où on n'a pas de
gouvernement
aucune mesure budgétaire n'est prise
aucune mesure d'économie en l'occurrence
reprise
ces mesures la devons à abandonner les
prises et plus on attend et plus les
mesures seront lourdes plus et monsieur
risque d'être compliqué politiquement
socio économiquement
d'où l'intérêt de rapidement pouvoir
former un gouvernement
attendre le moins longtemps possible et
ne pas laisser ce déficit continue à se
creuser se creuser encore est ce que
justement ça affecte la situation
économique et à quel point alors pour le
moment tous les indicateurs restent
extrêmement positif en belgique on a une
bonne économie on en est assez fier mais
voilà ça fait plus d'un an
aucun budget d'un pu être votée en tant
que tel aucune mesure concrète
d'économies comme j'expliquais n'ont pu
être prises
on est dans un gouvernement en affaires
courantes seulement les décisions du
jour le jour sont prises mais aucune
vision sur le long terme ne peut être
envisagée ça c'est pour le
socio-économique mais on sait qu'on doit
aussi prendre des mesures importantes en
termes d' urgence climatique en termes
de mobilité j'en passe et bien donné
entendu tout ceci pour le moment été mis
au frigo
on sait que l'on n'a encore loin d'avoir
un gouvernement est d'avoir un accord de
gouvernement de pouvoir prendre des
premières mesures et donc c'est vrai que
le pays tourne au ralenti au jour le
jour on ne le sent pas mais le poème
c'est que plus on attend plus le jour où
on aura un gouvernement à ce
gouvernement prend pas les mesures qui
sont nécessaires plus ça risque de se
sentir et d'où l'intérêt de parler le
plus vite possible alors david espère
tout de même c'est rare d'entendre ça un
citoyen qui nous dit en bas la situation
économique va bien vous trouverez peut
être français aujourd'hui vous dire ça
est ce que vous êtes
finalement certains ménages
je plaisante un petit peu mais qu'on ait
vraiment besoin d'un gouvernement pour
que les choses aillent bien finalement
votre situation prouve le contraire
je me fais exprès provocatrice
évidemment vous avez raison ce n'est pas
parce que nous n'avons pas un
gouvernement ici depuis un an qu'on n'a
pas eue avant et que les gouvernements
précédents n'a pas pris toute une série
de mesures structurelles qui nous
permettent justement de traverser cette
crise
bon an mal an cela dit cela n'empêche
que nous avons une même des difficultés
un déficit qui continue à se creuser
pour le moment on parvient à finir et
éviter de devoir prendre des mesures
computex qui a pas de gouvernement
mais si on ne le fait pas rapidement
jeudi le jour où le gouvernement sera
enfin mis en place là les mesures qui
sont prises de risque d'être compliqué
j'ai dit ah les années présente qu'on a
eu un gouvernement qui a pris des
décisions ambitieuses cse économiquement
lourdes est donc aujourd'hui dirait
qu'on vit un petit peu sur cet acquis là
n'empêche que si on veut avoir une
vision politique sur le long terme il
faut qu'on puisse former rapidement un
gouvernement et ne pas continuer dans
cette situation c'est alors important
vous appelez de vos voeux un changement
mais le blocage institutionnel se
poursuit les dernières législatives
n'ont pas permis de dégager une
coalition gouvernementale est ce que
vous avez l'espoir que dit parvient de
d'y parvenir un jour alors que j'avais
en belgique on a un système qui est un
petit peu dit change du système français
donc c'est un système qui est
proportionnel qui est pas majoritaire et
proportionnel veux dire par là que il ya
moins de entre huit et dix partis qui
sont susceptibles de pouvoir former une
coalition et vous compliqué c'est encore
un petit peu plus sachant que vous avez
des partis qui viennent du nord est
parti qui vient du sud pas pas la même
langue et surtout qui n'ont pas du tout
le même programme politique
historiquement les parties du sud sauf
le mien en l'occurrence un programme
dense riche de l'auche les protéines au
nord où un programme beaucoup plus de
droite je vous laisse imaginer les
négociations les discussions qui ont
lieu autour d'une table ça n'est pas
facile à concilier
c'est toute la problématique c'est tout
le débat autour du système proportionnel
belge qui n'est pas le même que le
système français qui ont pu majoritaire
est ce qu'une issue tout même sur du
moyen terme nous semble aujourd'hui
possible en réunion s'inscrit dans un
agenda de solutions on est ambitieux on
veut y croire vous allez en belgique
comment ça fonctionne après un
gouvernement après les élections
le roi est ce qu'on est une monarchie le
roi désigne il appelle un informateur ou
deux informateurs en l'occurrence avec
un pour le moment il ya deux
informateurs dont deux personnes qui
sont chargées
ils sont issus de partis politiques
importants en belgique et qui sont
chargés de réunir autour de la table les
autres partis politiques et de tenter de
trouver un compromis tenter de trouver
une coalition ici nous avons deux
informateurs qui ont été désignés au
moins deux descentes viennent à
l'instant notre guerre d'être reconduit
encore pour une semaine c'est la
troisième fois qu'ils sont reconduits
depuis depuis décembre et ce qu'ils ont
à chaque fois des délai de quinze jours
trois semaines sans dépendre un petit
peu de ce que le roi décide et dans une
semaine nous verrons un peu ce que des
informateurs ont rompu
je l'espère obtenir comme comme niveau
consensus compromis au cours de cette
semaine qui
de négociations mais voilà on veut
garder l'espoir même s'il faut pas se
voiler la face la situation est très
compliquée politiquement et
institutionnellement merci beaucoup
d'amis de leicester vice président du
mouvement réformateur bruxelles à doha
était avec nous candidat également la
présidence
l'organisation mondiale pour la santé
convoque le comité d'urgence sur le
coronavirus il doit se réunir demain
le but est de déterminer si l'épidémie
constitue ou non une alerte
internationale oms a par ailleurs
demandé au monde entier d'agir face à ce
nouveau virus
depuis son apparition fin décembre en
chine il a fait 132 morts cinq cas sont
confirmés en france environ lambert avec
pierre pissavy yvernault le corona virus
continue de se propager en europe
un premier cas de contamination autres
humains sur le sol européen a été
confirmé en allemagne
il l'aurait été après avoir rencontré
une personne venue de chine dans le
cadre de son travail
contrairement aux autres patients
signalés en europe qui ont quant à eux
été contaminée lors d'un séjour sur le
territoire chinois
le patient en question va bien cependant
il est toujours isolée dans un hôpital
de munich où il est placé sous
surveillance médicale
l' enquête sur la personne contaminée et
conduite avec la plus grande célérité
notamment dans son environnement
familial et professionnel qui ont déjà
été informés le risque de contamination
du patient reste très élevé
particulièrement dans son entourage
familial et dans les entreprises des
alentours qui ont évidemment été informé
en italie les passagers à bord d'un vol
en provenance de hong kong ont été
contrôlés hier par des professionnels de
santé lors de leur arrivée à l'aéroport
de milan en france
un quatrième cas étaient avérés ce mardi
le gouvernement français annoncé le
rapatriement de ses ressortissants de la
ville chinoise de wuhan l'avion
devrait être normalement à wuhan jeudi
soir donc ça veut dire par mercredi avec
le décalage horaire il arrivera jeudi
après-midi à roanne nous sommes en
constitution de l'équipe médicale qui va
accompagner cet avion l'objectif c'est
de pouvoir identifier sur place il y à
des personnes malades pour qu'elle fasse
l'objet d'une prise en charge
particulière et d'un transport
particulier et que nous ne mélangeons
pas des personnes malades et des
personnes sans symptômes
les autorités japonaises ont également
annoncé ce mardi la présence au japon
d'un cas de contamination chez un homme
qui ne s'est pas rendu en chine mais
ayant véhiculé des touristes en
provenance de one perso de la maladie
le nombre de victimes du coronavirus
s'est aggravée et passe aujourd'hui à
132 morts environ 6000 cas sont
confirmés dans toute la chine selon un
dernier bilan des autorités
et dans quelques instants en reste avec
notre débat sur le break site après plus
de trois ans et demi de crise de
tergiversations et de négociation tout
genre est ce le saut dans l'inconnu pour
le royaume-uni ou la promesse d'un âge
d'or
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les appuis
amna ne suis pas un terroriste iam je ne
suis pas un terroriste
je ne suis pas un terroriste de nos
jours peu importe vous êtes vous êtes
surveillés très probablement les drones
militaires ont fait des milliers de
morts innocents et peuvent attaquer à
tout moment n'importe où comme ils
veulent à plus de 10 mètres d'altitude
vous ne vous rendrez même pas compte que
vous êtes surveillés et en cas d'
attaque vous ne les voyez même pas
arrivé
wang lire ce que nous avons vu dans le
scénario d'après le 11 septembre c'est
que dans le cas du pakistan la cia reçu
l'autorisation en tuer ils bombardent
des villages il y à des villages à gaz
des maisons parfois il déclare avoir
supprimé un terroriste et plus tard on
voit en vie alors qu'ils ont ils tué il
m'avait fait tuer des enfants pour le
pays a fait pour le profit a aucune
comment pouvez-vous sourire
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
yelle parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer et découper une brochette
[Musique]
radio je crois que les éléphants
sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez des petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre j - de
donc avant le break site le divorce
entre londres et bruxelles sera
officielle vendredi à 23h mais c'est
sans surprise que les députés européens
ont voté ce soir à une large majorité
les modalités du traité de retrait il
s'agissait de la dernière étape majeure
dans la ratification de l'accord trois
ans et demi après le référendum à
clémence pital aux côtés des drapeaux
10,28 ligne ou jack flottant corps au
pied du parlement européen les
eurodéputés britanniques n'en sont pas
moins sur le départ je suis très
heureuse parce que maintenant les gens
vont vraiment voir que nous avons
franchi la première étape nous avons
techniquement quitter l'union européenne
et nous avons décidé cela il ya déjà
longtemps
donc c'est vraiment un soulagement dès
le 31 janvier le pays n'aura plus de
commissaire européen ni d'eurodéputés
plus de trois ans et demi après le
référendum
un point de non retour pour le chef de
file du bric site et opposant historique
à l'union européenne
nigel farrage le 31 janvier 2020 nous
quittons l'union européenne pour
franchir un point de non retour
c'est sa toute l'importance de cette
semaine qui est pour ce qui est de ce
que cela signifie pour nous sur le plan
constitutionnel de notre place dans le
monde
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante depuis qu'henri vite nous a
fait sortir de l'église de rome
il nous a fait sortir de l'église
romaine et nous quittons le traité de
rome
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible mais alors à quoi ressemblera
l'union amputé d'un de ses états membres
la perte sera d'abord démographique
l'union européenne verra partir plus de
66 millions d'habitants soit près de 13
% de sa population et plus de 15% de son
pib
sans les britanniques les mieux passera
en dessous de la barre symbolique
milliard d'habitants avec 446 millions
de personnes en son sein l'union est
également un membre permanent au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu ainsi qu'une de ces
deux puissances nucléaires
le secrétaire britannique à la défense a
tout de même voulu rassurer ses
partenaires européens
le brésil ne remet en aucun cas en cause
des questions de sécurité de l'europe
qui est vraiment très importante ou la
grande bretagne autant qu'elle l'est
pour les états membres de l'union
européenne
il n'y aura aucun problème et je pense
que vous savez que de relations
bilatérales ont été solides lorsque nous
sommes dans l'union européenne et ce
sera tout aussi fort après l'union
européenne
deux jours avant cette sortie historique
c'est une journée chargée en émotion qui
attendent des britanniques
le parlement européen vote aujourd'hui
pour sceller le traité de divorce dès le
31 janvier à 23h le royaume uni rentre
dans une période de transition jusqu'à
la fin de l'année pendant laquelle ils
continueront d'appliquer les règles
européennes
un laps de temps pour négocier la
nouvelle relation qu'entretiendrait à
londres et bruxelles
le break 6 et les objets de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
pour en débattre sur ce plateau françois
pour les métis journaliste et auteur du
break site une chance point
d'interrogation c'est important de
préciser aux éditions hauteur du monde
bonsoir à vous françois pour les matisse
à ses côtés pierre lévy rédacteur en
chef de rupture bonsoir pierre lévy
merci d'être avec nous avec votre une en
exclusivité pour nous ce soir enfin
libre c'est ça c'est ça
voilà d'arrêt dans deux jours et nous
avons évidemment consacré une grande
place à cet événement tout à fait
historique cela un jour de fête pour
vous peut-être moins de l'autre côté
alors fait pour les pro ben brik sitter
larmes pour les autres aujourd'hui
messieurs sait-on vraiment qui a raison
de pleurer et qui a raison de se réjouir
ce qu on le sait avec certitude françois
paul et métis
on ne sait pas encore quand je vois
d'ailleurs la une de votre journal
enfin libre je me pose des questions
parce que sont ils véritablement libre à
partir d'après-demain je n'en suis pas
persuadé pourquoi parce que les enjeux
vont être énormes pour la difficulté
elle commence après demain elle y avait
déjà une difficulté parce qu'il y avait
une confusion sur les négociations de
sortie
une fois qu'ils seront sortis c'est pas
fini les choses ne changent pas
véritablement pendant une année il va y
avoir des négociations pour savoir quel
type de rapport on va essayer d'imaginer
avec les britanniques
et là il ya un véritable pari est sale
c'est sur ce sujet là que je pense qui
est véritable inconnue avec boris
johnson le connaissant un peu je pense
qu'il est un peu imprévisible et il a
une option entre deux options qui sont
possibles et qui sont totalement
différentes et dont les conséquences
sont radicalement différentes soit une
option qui consiste à dire on est libre
donc auront tout ce qui nous unit c'est
à union européenne on change tout la
réglementation cette augmentation
tatillonne qui était insupportable et
c'est rare on change nos liens
commerciaux ou on change tout ce qui
nous unit
sur le plan réglementaire avec l'europe
et on le fait en faisant ça il peut le
faire mais il risque de se couper de
l'accès au marché unique
or une des conditions pour lequel le
président pourrait fonctionner c'est
qu'il conserve quand même un certain
nombre d' avantages et ses avantages
c'est notamment l'accès au marché unique
et si ils optent pour cette position
dans laquelle effectivement ils vont
devoir se plier sans y participer à la
discipline marché unique
c'est une autre configuration on est
dans deux configurations qui sont pas du
tout qu'ils veulent pas du tout dire les
mêmes choses sur le plan politique alors
je vous rejoindrai sur un point
effectivement l'histoire n'est pas finie
ça c'est vrai acton quand même un
événement de portée historique pour la
première fois un pays de l'union
européenne décide de la quitter
alors ça n'a pas été sans mal il ya eu
des guérillas à la fois parlementaires
et de bruxelles qui a tout fait pour que
la secte ne laisse pas partir cette
percée de ce pays d'ici dans quelque
sorte
et finalement ce dont notre journal n'a
jamais douté à aucun moment nous n'avons
eu l'idée qu'il pouvait y avoir un doute
le brésil arrive c'est à dire que
politiquement et juridiquement la
l'union européenne perd en quelque sorte
le royaume uni alors là où vous avez
raison c'est que sur le plan économique
il va y avoir encore pendant les mois
qui viennent des négociations
importantes pour déterminer le type de
relations à venir entre les deux parties
alors chaque partie explique qu'on peut
arriver à un accord mais en effet vous
avez raison il ya des choix pour ma part
je ne crois pas du tout que boris
johnson opte pour une solution qui
serait en quelque sorte un faubourg
existe c'est à dire on en sort mais en
réalité on continue à appliquer des
règles même si on n'est pas représenté
au sommet au sein des institutions tout
ce qu'il a jusqu'à présent dit effet a
été conforme à ce qu'il a annoncé à
savoir ombres ont de manière claire et
nette petit paradoxe quand même cruel
pour les pour ceux qui souhaitaient
rester dans une baignoire westminster
pendant des mois et des mois les députés
pro l'union européenne ont bloqué ont
tout fait pour faire capoter l'accord
qui avait négocié theresa may
avec bruxelles un accord qui était
finalement beaucoup plus où elle avait
dû d'ailleurs compte tenu de son manque
de majorité à faire concessions pour
concessions mais qui a quand même été
bloqués et boris johnson est arrivé en
disant d'accord ou pas d'accord de toute
façon on va sortir et on tape en quelque
sorte du poing sur la table
il a obtenu un accord alors certes avec
des concessions sur l'irlande du nord
mais fondamentalement qui est beaucoup
plus net certains iraient beaucoup plus
dur que ce que les antilles break sitter
avait fait dérailler donc d'une certaine
manière quand vous posez des questions
j'en termine là dessus qu'ils n'ont pas
l'écouter justement boris johnson à
cette époque alors justement terminé on
écoutera on va l'entendre
et d'ailleurs quand on écoute ce qui dit
maintenant vous verrez que il tient ce
qu'il dit et ça veut pas dire que dans
notre journal on est des partisans
absolue de boris johnson mais il faut
reconnaître les choses et donc qui peut
se réjouir et qui peut pleurer mais nous
nous considérons qu aussi bien au
royaume uni que dans le reste de
l'europe ceux qui peuvent se réjouir
c'est ceux qui se considèrent que la
question du brésil s'était d'abord une
question politique
gardons-nous ou plutôt reconquerrons
nous la liberté de décider de notre
avenir politiquement ou pas alors ben
johnson justement c'était à l'époque car
on va l'entendre en décembre dernier le
premier ministre qui promettait l'âge
d'or je ne pense pas qu'il soit avant ou
invraisemblable de dire qu'un nouvel âge
d'or pour ce royaume uni est maintenant
à portée de main
et malgré les moqueries malgré la
négativité malgré le scepticisme que
vous entendez de l'autre goûter nous
travaillerons d'arrache-pied pour le
réaliser alors vous le disiez françois
pour les matisse tout reste à faire ça
peut tomber dans un camp comme dans
l'autre on entendait le chantre du fric
si tu es et binou françois asselineau
tout à l'heure qui nous disaient mais
regardez et boris johnson à augmenter le
smic il va investir des milliards dont
les urgences et la question mais que ces
voiliers avec quel argent parce que il
faut que les quasi joignant exactement
mais en tout cas il l'a fait il a déjà
augmenter le smic
c'est ce que ceux qui fantasment
peut-être sur les sorties des pays se
disent voilà on a les pieds les mains
liées par par l'union européenne
responsable de tous les maux qu est ce
que vous leur répondez vous je crois
qu'il suffit de voir la complication
énorme qu'a représenté la sortie de la
grande-bretagne de l'union européenne et
ses deux années de négociations de
d'allers retours qui s'entendait pas
toutes les complications liées à la
sortie pour montrer que ça désespère et
beaucoup de candidats à la sortie
beaucoup de pays qui auraient pu être
tentés effectivement par suivre
l'exemple de la grande bretagne ont
réfléchi à deux fois et aujourd'hui vous
voyez vous ne voyez pas un seul pays de
l'union européenne qui a envie pour
l'instant ou même qu'ils l'expriment
même en france où des certains part si
je pense notamment à droite envisager
très nettement afrique cite ces parties
là on n'en parle plus donc aujourd'hui
toutes ces complications montre que
sortir de l'union européenne c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît
et boris johnson n'a pas encore dit ses
véritables intentions
et ça c'est une très grande incertitude
en particulier pour l'avenir de
l'économie britannique
qu'est ce que vous craignez le plus
pierre lévy le beurre et l'argent du
beurre vous lancer pour boris johnson
qui a en tout cas certainement cette
ambition avec la crémière réagir
sur les miliaires est ce que vous avez
dit d'abord sur le smic le salaire
minimum britannique et avec quel argent
ccc le secteur privé donc évidemment les
chambres de commerce le patronat a crié
comme tous les patronats du monde quand
on les contraint à augmenter les
salaires que jamais ça ne serait
possible mais non en fait ça se voit ça
se fera et l'économie britannique non
seulement le son de vente et celle de
santé non seulement ne sombrera pas mais
les tous les éléments parce qu'on vient
finalement vivre un tournant depuis plus
de trois ans il y a eu donc cette
guérilla qui a donné l'impression que
c'est un enfer dont on ne peut sortir
que le chaos et que au fond toutes les
catastrophes nous attendent au coin de
la rue et bien maintenant on va voir et
chaque jour qui passe sans que le
royaume uni ne sombre dans la manche est
un démenti cinglant à ceux qui nous
expliquait que ça allait être un
cataclysme
alors il faut quand même se rappeler
tout ce qu'on nous a expliqué tout ce
qu'on vous a annoncé tous les
cataclysmes je pense par exemple
monsieur mark carney qui était jusqu'à
peu le gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre qui expliquait en 2016 ça
allait être une catastrophe absolue
aujourd'hui il est devenu responsable de
l'onu pour le climat ils annoncent
d'autres catastrophes
quoi qu'il en soit les cataclysmes en
question non seulement ne sont pas en
passe de se produire mais tous les
éléments tous les indicateurs tous les
indices qu'on connaît wihr plutôt au
vert que ce soit en matière de chômage
et donc d'emplois que ça soit en matière
d'investissements que ce soit en matière
de croissance et même de prévisions de
croissance le fmi qui faisait partie des
élites mondialisées qui prédisaient le
pire doit bien reconnaître que en effet
ce n'est pas exactement les catastrophes
annoncées et donc monsieur le juge cité
monsieur carmet disait alors qu'ils
disaient sale est une catastrophe a lié
le le mieux n'est pas encore assurée
voilà comment
mais est-ce qu'on a quand même le recul
nécessaire je vous invite à écouter
michel barnier négociateur en chef pour
qui certains pans de l'industrie seront
confrontés à des retombées négatives
il est très clair qu'il y aura des
conséquences négatives
le ministre des finances s'agit de david
a reconnu la semaine dernière que
certains points de l'industrie seront
confrontés à des retombées négatives
t'as pas envie dustrit où il fait chaud
et négatives fallout quel que soit
l'accord que nous atteindrons sur notre
future relation
le ver existera toujours une opération
visant à limiter les déguerpis matters
of damage limitée chez o2 uk h chose
tout le royaume uni a choisi de devenir
un pays tiers de quitter le marché
unique et l'union douanière de laisser
derrière lui le cadre de règles communes
de lieux
la surveillance commune et la cour de
justice caunois kafkaïenne rouge comme
une supervision and common cohorte
objectif ia ciuntu qu'il a choisi de
créer deux espaces réglementaire cela
rend impossible à commerçants section
frictionne lèche trade in possible mack
cité jeune roumaine to be aware exit et
est aussi censé avoir pour objectif une
grande bretagne mondiale mais pour nous
il franchement ces lieux qui contribue à
rendre les états membres plus tourné
vers le reste du monde
mort clôt bon pierre lévy on agite
encore le chiffon rouge c'est du bluff
alors qu'une chose soit bien clair dans
notre journal nous n'avons jamais
affirmer ou analyser que la réalisation
du brésil
elle est automatiquement et
mécaniquement créer un paradis sur terre
simplement le breakbeat et je les dis
d'abord et avant tout un enjeu politique
c'est à dire que les britanniques
reconquiert la liberté de décider de
leur politique économique
bonne ou mauvaise avant elle ne pouvait
que dépendre de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui ils ont la liberté de
choisir
c'est ça l'essentiel alors maintenant
effectivement il y a un certain de
signes qui annoncent qu'ils semblent
indiquer que les catastrophes annoncées
ne sont pas produites et ne sont pas en
passe de se
rires je dis pas que c'est parce que le
brésil va créer des miracles simplement
tout ce qu'on nous avait expliqué
s'avèrent inexactes et donc on va voir
les choses mais encore une fois la
liberté d'un peuple de décider de son de
son sort c'est quand même l'essentiel
mais pas tout ça de vrai dans la mesure
où ces c'est pas une véritable liberté
qu'ils auront reconquise le royaume uni
lorsqu'il était dans l'union européenne
faisait partie du lap le plus grande une
des deux plus grandes puissances
commerciales du monde
aujourd'hui le royaume uni va se trouver
seul à devoir renégocier une centaine
d'accords commerciaux séparément avec
l'ensemble des pays à se trouver dans
une position de très grande infériorité
lorsqu'il devra s'adresser par exemple
aux états unis par exemple à la chine où
son poids ne sera pas du tout le même
que lorsqu'il faisait partie d'un
ensemble beaucoup plus de puissance qui
est l union européenne
ça il ne mesure pas encore deuxième
chose que je note des pans entiers de
l'industrie sont directement menacés je
parle je pense à l'industrie aux deux
automobiles
je pense à airbus je pense à l'ensemble
de secteurs qui vont voir probablement
des débuts de rapatriement sur le
continent de d'activité industrielle
donc il va y avoir énormément de
conséquence je pense aussi que en partie
les gens qui ont voté en faveur du bric
site et notamment ceux qui sont au
centre de l'angleterre vont devoir
réaliser que cette partie de
l'angleterre a bénéficié des deux
régionales absolument considérable que
pour l'instant le gouvernement
britannique n'a pas imaginé la manière
dont elles pourraient les compenser il
ya un certain nombre de conséquences qui
n'ont pas été mesuré donc c'est alors je
suis je ne prédis pas la catastrophe je
fais pas partie de ceux qui prédisent la
catastrophe que fait partie de ceux qui
disent qu'il y aura des conséquences
lourdes pour la grande bretagne
oui l esi pierre les conséquences
lourdes
encore une fois ce sera des conséquences
d'une politique qui pourrait être menée
et décider librement
il ya un point sur lequel je ne vous
suis pas c'est l'idée au fond que dans
le monde dans lequel on vit
plus on est gros et puissant lyons porte
et qu'il faut avoir en quelque sorte
l'effet de taille pour peser en quelque
sorte ça c'est un discours qu'on connaît
bien qui est aussi celui d'une critique
à votre guerre c'est cela aussi celui de
monsieur barnier on comprend bien que
monsieur barnier va pas dire c'est
formidable maintenant puisqu'il a tout
fait pendant trois ans pour rendre la
vie impossible l'asbr exit mais voilà on
est onze heures tu écoutais sais c'est
pas parce qu'on est gros et puissant
qu'on s'en sort mieux
on est venus regarder je prends
l'exemple plus le plus caricatural si je
puis dire la suisse qui est qui qui un
certain type d'accords sectoriels avec
l'union européenne mais qui n'est en
aucune manière tributaire est contrainte
par des décisions politiques
on peut pas dire que la suisse est quand
même et soit une grande puissance
économique dans le monde
eh bien personne n'a entendu que la
suisse sombret avait une situation
catastrophique au contraire même s'il a
rien et paradisiaque
on peut penser qu'elle s'en sort plutôt
mieux père et elle n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne ne vire à comme la
suisa et la norvège sont des pays qui
finalement ce proche suivent union
européenne suive les réglementations
européennes et le fait de simplement les
chefs sans y participer directement
fonds qui sont dans une situation qui va
très bien c'est pour ça que je pense
très raisonnablement que si boris
johnson suit la voie assez prévisible
restés très proches venus en europe et
dans la foi dans la règlementation à la
fois dans les accords etc
il a plus de chance finalement de
maintenir à un certain niveau de
puissance économique de son pays que si
il choisit la rupture totale gens
manifestement bruxelles et l'air de lui
faire les yeux doux à l inverse les yeux
doux la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen
juste avant ce vote un aujourd'hui voilà
avait une tonalité très douce heureuse
on ne vous aimera toujours on sera
jamais très loin on n'est pas trop dans
le ton d'un d'un divorce non consenti un
mais ces terres qui est maintenant il ya
peu plus faire autrement il faut bien
qu'elle fasse de nécessité vertu à
l'école alae ça sera le break si dur les
foudres de vaud là on leur avait prédit
cela quand même aux anglais c'est vrai
mais on leur avait prédit les pires
catastrophes s'il votait pour sortir de
l'union européenne l'a d'abord dans
trois ans tout a été fait encore une
fois je suis désolée de me répéter mais
on l'a vécu tout ce mois après mois g et
quelquefois invité sur ce plateau et à
chaque fois il y avait de nouveaux
obstacles de nouvelles embûches qui
résulte est pour l'essentiel la volonté
de bruxelles et des antilles bré exit
d'autre part le royaume-uni d' de faire
capoter tout cela c'était une illusion
donc les choses maintenant parce qu'on
ne vit pas on n'est plus à une époque où
l'on pouvait comme ça s'est fait en
france comme ça s'est fait en irlande
comme ça s'est fait au danemark où on
pouvait inverser en quelque sorte le
verdict populaire parce qu'il faut quand
même rappeler ceux ci on parle économie
c'est normal qu'on réfléchisse sur les
concernant
mais rappelons nous quand même
l'essentiel si aujourd'hui la grande
bretagne sort de l'union européenne
c'est parce que son peuple
on a décidé ainsi en 2016 et donc c'est
le respect du verdict démocratique tout
à fait et donc je sorte d'accord là
dessus et est donc mais c'est
l'essentiel
après une fois créer cette nouvelle
situation l'union européenne a autant
intérêt à faire entre guillemets les
yeux doux au royaume-uni que l' inverse
contrairement à ce qu'elle dit est donc
je suis tout à fait convaincu qu'il y
aura sous une forme que personne d'aucun
on est encore des relations maintenue
bien entendu n'y a pas une guerre
travers de la manche je vous rappelle
quand même qu'en général un accord
commercial se trouvait à un véritable
accord tu sais le ciel avec partie
seulement général ces deux trois voire
quatre voies larges et là johnson a fait
le pari de le mettre sur une année vers
l'arrivée au au 31 décembre 2008 mais
regardez si jamais si jamais il n'y
arrive pas mais regardez un retombe dans
l'hypothèse d'un break 6-3 - il a fallu
trois ans pour nous arriver à se sortir
d'une situation inextricable
au moment où boris johnson arrive
dis moi je vais régler la situation en
deux mois et de fait il a presque parce
que son parlement le parlement tel qu il
est l a contraint à le 10 août donc ça
il ya eu le temps de la dissolution le
boris johnson a quasiment tenu parole
alors que personne je vous rappelle que
je dis juste en une phrase mais il y
avait eu un premier accord signé j'en ai
parlé entre theresa may et dru seul cet
accord qui avait été long à se délier et
une fois signée bruxelles les vingt-sept
avaient dit il n'est pas question qu'on
y touche une seule virgule
c'est un ces signes essais signés on ne
fera aucune concession supplémentaire de
quelques natures que soient ses l'accord
point bas et c'est ce que je vous disais
le temps le ton a changé mais le ton a
forcément changé sauf a déclaré la
guerre à la grande bretagne
donc hier chaque partie a intérêt à ce
que les relations non seulement
commercial mais de sécurité de défense
de soi évidemment soit un tiers à jouer
des jeux dangereux
par exemple si boris johnson imagine
tout d'un coup de dire bon ça y est les
impôts on les descend en flèche ont fait
de la concurrence fiscale ont créé une
forme de singapour de européen je me
permets de vous interrompre sur
singapour c'est très drôle
je me suis fait si c'est le développer
quand même pas chasse à l'homme
élections dont j'ai le moment là des
moments où à s'affranchir d'un minimum
de règles de bon comportement de
relations commerciales effectivement là
on se met dans une position où on est
plus en recherche d'un accord on en est
votre position dans lesquels on devient
opposé opposants et donc dans ce cas là
effectivement se pose la véritable
question parce que je rappelle quand
même que pour le royaume-uni l'important
c'est de garder des avantages d'un accès
au marché européen
c'est ça qui est en cause excusez-moi
j'ai j'étais un peu vif à vous attendre
à lui attendre la fin bien d'entendre un
seul mot singapour qui m'a fait réagir
oui absolument
ça me fait réagir c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend souvent le risque existe
dit on que boris johnson opte pour une
option singapour sur tamise alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire charger cave une
sorte de dumping fiscal social
environnement pas de tout ce qu'on
voudra et mais c'est très drôle parce
que
l'union européenne vient de signer un
accord commercial avec singapour donc si
c'était un modèle de déréglementation on
le saurait donc prendre cet exemple en
disant ça va être singapour sur tamise
singapour en réalité elle vient de
signer avec l'union européenne accorde
un accord de libre échange
donc ouais je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
pense que le libre échange et la panacée
qui va régler toutes les questions non
je n'en suis pas un fanatique mais ça
c'est donc nous analyse c'est chacun que
évidemment avoir sa propre sa propre
analyse
je ne crois pas du tout que boris
johnson va opter pour dire on a fait le
break site
mais on va continuer à appliquer les
mêmes règles ce serait d'abord un
suicide politique tout simplement
et en plus je pense que la manière de le
dire nous on peut le faire sortir
nous sommes à bassa ne pourra échapper à
personne et ça ne pourrait échapper à
personne
d'autant que d'autant que l'union
européenne souhaiterait cela et donc ne
manquera pas ne manquerait pas de crier
évidemment victoire si en effet boris
johnson accepté de se mettre sous le
contrôle de la cour de justice
européenne par exemple pour régler les
différends ou d'accepter que les règles
en termes dé change de commerce de
réglementation divers et variés
s'alignaient de manière dynamique en
plus sur celle de l'union européenne
ça serait non seulement un suicide
politique mais j'ai alors on discute et
un petit peu avant l'émission nous
sommes d'accord sur un point cinq boris
johnson est un homme qui est flexible
est un homme c'est un autre à
l'humaniste pragmatique si l'on veut
alors falloir donc invisible mais et je
crois que c'est également un homme qui a
une vision à long terme et les zincs
l'intérêt de son parti si je puis dire
c'est d'être là où on ne l'attend pas
c'est à dire de faire une politique qui
n'est pas du tout traditionnellement
celle des tories par exemple vous avez
vu des routes une partie des
conservateurs seulement vous avez eues
il vient par exemple de kung fu et une
compagnie privée d'aviation est
complètement et le telegraph analyser ça
comme une trahison du thatchérisme
en quelque sorte donc et il parle
d'investissements publics massifs
notamment en direction des régions
favorisées
s'il veut tenir tout ça et vous
ou pire les vies cet argent parce que
c'est alors c'est ce que poser comme
question je ne sais pas s'il va le
trouver là où je souhaiterais qu'il le
trouve personnellement je pense que
comme dans la plupart des pays de
l'union européenne les moyens financiers
existent pour peu que la production ne
bénéficient pas de manière déséquilibrée
au capital au détriment du travail mais
ça c'est une autre émission au pied du
lit voilà donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de souci sur le fait que les moyens
existent les prendre at il effectivement
la salle histoire de le dire a encore
une fois moi je ne suis pas un fanatique
de boris johnson j'essaye de comprendre
sa logique et je crois comprendre que
politiquement il souhaite ancrer son
parti dans des classes populaires qui
sont celles qui ont fait gagner le
brésil était qui ont fait gagner boris
johnson qui l'a piqué au labour et qu'
ils souhaitent en quelque sorte
conserver pour le parti tory le modeler
fin françois pour les motifs
moi je note simplement en ayant suivi la
séance du parlement européen cet après
midi que tout le monde personne n'a
remis en cause l'appartenance à l'europe
pas l'union européenne notamment par les
peuples pas l'heure aucun nous sommes
européens
nous sommes tout le monde à lui même
même un nul fages
ce qui veut dire quelque part que
effectivement cette europe qui nous faut
avec laquelle nous fonctionnons dépasse
celle qui satisfaisante mais que
globalement l'ensemble des peuples
considère qu'ils sont partis protestants
au 17 ans sont décédées les politiques
l'ensemble des élites politiques pas des
peuples merci merci messieurs françois
pour les métis pierre lévy d'avoir
accepté le jeu du débat est resté avec
nous dans quelques instants un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fonio et sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrivait
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les systèmes de plis parce que cela
permet de développer de très grandes
surfaces à l'intérieur de tout petits
espaces ce n'est donc pas surprenant de
voir de l'origami dans les selles
d'insectes et dans les feuilles dans
l'intestin
on peut même voir des système de pliage
semblables sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vis dans cet environnement depuis ma
naissance je veux voir quelque chose qui
est uniquement à moi un espace kim
appartiendrait à moi tout seul tout
d'abord il a dit je ne veux plus aller à
l'école c'est comme ça que ça a commencé
ce travail nous manque beaucoup
c'est un problème typiquement japonais
est profondément ancré dans notre
culture et notre société on le retrouve
surtout chez les jeunes japonais j'ai
même eu l'impression d'être aimé par qui
que ce soit je me suis jamais senti aimé
la manière
[Musique]
tout aussi déterminé mais moins nombreux
dans les rues pour cette huitième
journée de mobilisation
interprofessionnelle aujourd'hui contre
le projet de réforme des retraites qui a
commencé son parcours législatif
à la veille de l'ouverture de la
conférence sur le financement la cfdt
seul grand syndicat soutenir un système
universel a réclamé des avancées
sociales
amy netanyahu se rend à mouscou
lendemain de l'annoncé du plan de paix
au moyen-orient de donald trump le
premier ministre israélien doit
d'exposer au chef du kremlin le texte du
président américain rejetées par les
palestiniens
et une grande partie de la communauté
internationale la belgique privée de
gouvernement depuis plus d'un an dans
une situation loin d'être inédite pour
le plat pays si les affaires portion
traité n'y a ni budget voté ni politique
engagée et l'impasse politique qui fait
resurgir l'hypothèse d'un référendum sur
la répartie sur la partition du pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette nouvelle demi heure
d'information huitième jour de
mobilisation nationale
interprofessionnelle contre la réforme
des retraites alors qu'une nouvelle
journée de grèves et de manifestations
est annoncée le 6 février prochain
manifestation dont en région aujourd'hui
dans la capitale à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats la cgt fo en tête ils étaient
180 milles à paris selon la cgt 13 mille
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
beaucoup moins donc la dernière fois
leurs objectifs le retrait du texte
adopté vendredi en conseil des ministres
rassemblement plutôt calme malgré treize
interpellations parmi les manifestants
jean luc mélenchon de la france
insoumise et yves veyrier secrétaire
général de force ouvrière
évidemment le placer ici de montrer que
on est solidaires mais surtout il faut
dire une chose le mouvement est en train
de se diffuser en profondeur dans le
pays et on oblige le gouvernement à une
espèce de contre-offensive en mouvement
donc tous les jours il doit la
question'' ya matière à réformer mais il
faut réformer pour faire partir les gens
à plat chantant la nuitée jackson c'est
trop tôt sachez qu'on ne laissera pas
détourner l'attention du système
universel de retraite par points par
cette conférence nous notre objectif
c'est de finir par convaincre
on va peser on va aller voir les
parlementaires en leur disant y compris
vous même vous êtes traité à la légère
le conseil d'état souligne qu'il ya
beaucoup d' ordonnances prévues dans le
projet de loi autrement dit y compris on
passe d'une certaine manière par dessus
le rôle du législateur le parlement et
avec une visibilité absolument flou de
ce que sera finalement il concrètement
le droit à la retraite demain avec ce
projet de loi et contestation dans la
rue donc mais également à l'assemblée
nationale si le conseil d'état se montre
critique quatre groupes d'opposition
demandent une saisine du conseil
constitutionnel aux sujets de l'étude
d'impact jugée incomplète
le pcf présente un contre projet
prévoyant un âge de départ à la retraite
à 60 ans les républicains demandent
un nouveau texte et dénoncent la
précipitation et les matrices mme du
gouvernement l'exécutif qui appelle au
calme le premier ministre edouard
philippe dit ne pas avoir peur du champ
de braise un élément du système
je n'ai pas peur du débat parlementaire
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat ce
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils disent que ce
débat devrait prendre la forme d'un
champ de braise ne disent pas quelque
chose auquel je crois
nous allons tenir le calendrier que nous
nous sommes fixés monsieur le président
marseille et le calendrier que nous
avons fixée c'est effectivement la
présentation d'un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres c'était vendredi
dernier et l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale puis par le sénat au cours du
premier semestre de ce texte de façon à
ce que nous puissions espérer
je ne veux pas préjuger de l'issue du
débat parlementaire mais c'est en tout
cas l'objectif que nous nous fixons une
adoption du texte avant l'interruption
estivale
pour marie claire cailletaud diligente
confédéral cgt les négociations entre la
cgt le premier ministre lors de la
conférence sur le financement demain
s'annonce compliquée pour l'instant le
ce qu'on sait c'est que ça va être une
réunion de trois heures de 14h30 à 17h30
le premier ministre va parler mais d'une
part donc vous c'est quand même
visiblement une grosse opération de
communication
néanmoins la cgt sera présente elle n'a
jamais fait la chaise vide
donc elle sera présente mais si vous
voulez ce qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement après ministre c'est qu'on
avait un cadre extrêmement contre un
style qu'on rentre dans une boîte et
puis visiblement il n'y a qu'une porte
de sortie c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
parler d'augmentation des cotisations
sociales on peut pas parler des
exonérations de cotisations des
entreprises enfin voilà il ya beaucoup
de sujets qui sont à bout qui font que
de fait la sortie et les flécher sur
l'augmentation du temps de travail donc
il faut pas prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles n'ont plus qu'à des
propositions et donc demain on va mettre
sur la table nos propositions parce
qu'on dit cui il faut que le système il
évolué pour prendre en compte tous les
nouveaux métiers pour prendre en compte
justement les carrières qui sont h f il
ya beaucoup de situations qui doivent
notre système doit être amélioré et on a
des propositions pour l'améliorer et si
on va les mettre sur un table demain
mais comment fait depuis deux ans et
heureusement visiblement on n'est pas du
tout entendu après washington hier
moscou aujourd'hui et demain bayemi
netanyahu va plaider en faveur du plan
de paix de donald trump pour le
moyen-orient le premier ministre
israélien doit rencontrer vladimir
poutine alors que le texte est rejeté
par l'autorité palestinienne
grégoire dos est annoncée depuis des
mois le plan de paix américain était
dévoilée ce mardi en grande pompe avec
une absence notable celle de la
palestine l'une des deux parties
concernées donald trump et benyamin
nétanyahou main dans la main ont
présenté un plan qualifié d' accord du
siècle par le président américain
un projet confié au printemps 2017 au
gendre et conseiller du locataire de la
maison blanche
jared kushner un des points les plus
sensibles de ce document déjà
controversé la reconnaissance par les
états unis de la souveraineté d'israël
sur les colonies dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés
le président américain a également
précisé que jérusalem restera la
capitale indivisible d'israël
la partie est de la ville est seulement
suggéré par washington pour devenir la
capitale d'un éventuel état palestinien
en état qui verrait le jour sous
conditions parmi lesquelles un rejet
clair du terrorisme
trump et enthousiaste au moment de
parler de ce nouveau plan de paix la
vision présence une occasion gagnant
gagnant pour les deux parties une
solution réaliste at the escape qui
résout le risque que représente un état
palestinien pour la sécurité d'israël
aujourd'hui israël fait un grand pas
vers la paix le premier ministre
israélien s'est lui aussi grandement
félicité de cet accord
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020 car ce jour là vous êtes
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître la souveraineté d'israël sur
des zones comme la judée samarie qui
sont vitales pour notre sécurité et qui
sont au coeur de notre patrimoine
côté palestinien les réactions sont aux
antipodes
malgré des désaccords récurrents avec le
fatah le hamas s'est joint la réunion
d'urgence programmée
hier par le président mahmoud abbas ce
dernier a rejeté en bloc cet accord je
veux dire aux deux trump et netanyahu
que jérusalem n'est pas à vendre
que tous nos droits ne sont pas à vendre
ni à négocier et que votre accord de
conspiration ne passera pas la colère
s'est aussi exprimée dans les rues
palestiniennes
à la suite de l'annoncé commune de
donald trump et benyamin nétanyahou les
manifestants ont témoigné de leur
opposition au projet porté par
washington
s'estimant perdant sur toute la ligne un
plan qui en définitive peu de chance de
connaître un meilleur sort que les
précédentes tentatives américaines au
lendemain de l'annoncé du deal du siècle
par donald trump les palestiniens
rejette les propositions blog stéphane
liégeois et thomas ont passé la journée
dans la ville de ramallah pour prendre
le pouls sur place
ici à ramallah beaucoup de gens si ce
n'est de dire tout le monde a regardé
l'annoncé hier de donald trump et de
benyamin nétanyahou pour ce qui est
présenté par le président américain
comme un plan de paix ambitieux mais ici
vous l'imaginez les réactions sont vives
et l'opposition est totale au plan
annoncé hier par le président américain
c'est mauvais pour tous les policiers
pour b 1 0 ap dans les mondes pour tout
le monde arabe ainsi en cisjordanie où
beaucoup de gens sont dans la rue dans
toute la région
il va s'abaisser deal du siècle n'est
pas bon pour le peuple palestinien
ceci est notre terre elle était
prédestiné dans le passé et les coûts
qui viendra dans le futur
[Musique]
au moment où donald trump recevait à
washington benyamin nétanyahou pour l'
annonce de son plan de paix pour le
proche-orient une réunion se tenait en
territoire palestinien autour du
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas qu'on voit sur cette photo
autour de la table des représentants du
hamas et du fatah de mouvements qui ne
sont pourtant pas du tout sur la même
ligne politique une réunion donc quasi
historique ici en territoire palestinien
et qui fait donc la une des journaux ici
dans les lois de la science physique
toute chose sur laquelle on n'a plus
trop de pression on finit par exploser
vous voyez cette impression elbaz qu'ils
accentuent la pression les choses vont
se mettre à exploser donc ce sont eux
qui mettent la pression et tous les gens
à exposer à quoi vous attendez vous je
peux donner votre cadeau à quelqu'un
d'autre
accepteriez cela me laisser prendre
comme nous les donner à cet homme-là
et voilà ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire ça ne fonctionnera pas croyez moi
tant qu'il restera un palestinien vivant
il n'acceptera pas cette solution
quelques instants après l'annnonce du
fameux plan de paix par donald trump des
centaines de palestiniens sont descendus
dans les rues brûlant des portraits à
l'effigié du locataire de la maison
blanche ou encore brûlant des drapeaux
israéliens ou américains
ces manifestations ont causé des
blessures d'au moins 13 personnes en
cisjordanie au lendemain de ces
manifestations
la situation est calme ici à ramallah
mais la colère est intacte dans l'esprit
d'un certain nombre d'habitants et les
regards sont désormais tournés vers la
journée de vendredi qui sera un bon
indicateur du niveau de colère chez les
palestiniens le vendredi est une journée
traditionnellement marquée par de fortes
mobilisations
mais ici la colère a peut-être été
remplacée par une certaine forme de
lassitude
cela fait maintenant plus d'un an que la
belgique est sans véritable gouvernement
407 jours exactement comment le pays en
est arrivé là et quelles sont les
conséquences d'une telle situation le
reportage à bruxelles des stèles farge
et de renault parquet sur un récit des
midis goût gâche un gouvernement
officiel presse qu'un vague souvenir
pour les belges depuis la démission du
premier ministre charles michel le 18
décembre 2018
la belgique est dirigée par un
gouvernement d'affaires courantes dont
les compétences sont limitées
ce contexte n'est pas étranger au belge
en 2010 et 2011 déjà l'absence de
gouvernement dans le pays avait duré
cinq cent quarante et un jours
alors aujourd'hui c'est avec résilience
qu'ils prennent la situation
je pense qu'à un moment oui ils vont ils
vont quand même trouvé trouvé un conte
premier et ça prendra encore du temps
on accepte la situation j'espère quand
même que ça va se débloquer mais dans le
quotidien en tout cas j'ai envie de la
vie quotidienne tous les jours on est on
est assez peu impacté on a déjà vécu
cette situation et c'est toujours la
même chose faite avec souvent la nva et
puis les autres partis socialistes qui
ne veulent pas former de gouvernement
avec la nva
il a beaucoup de gens qui parlent de de
la formation du gouvernement mais la vie
se roule encore donc
l'impasse politique dans laquelle se
trouve le pays est en partie due à la
fracture entre le nord du territoire
une flandre très à droite et le sud la
wallonie qui elles votent
majoritairement à bouche à cela
s'ajoutent des mésententes entre des
partis comme le ps et le nva incapable
de former un gouvernement
mais pour ces élus l'issue de cette
crise politique que vit la belgique
passe forcément par une coalition
il faut maintenant que les personnes
veuillent bien vraiment se mettre autour
de la table on n'en est pas encore là on
est toujours au stade d'informations
avec certains partis clés de la venue de
pays qui bloque
et donc maintenant on voudrait que
chacun puisse venir autour de la table
avec un peu de bonne volonté et trouver
vraiment des solutions la belgique est
dans une impasse qui est du jamais vu
inédit savez qu'aujourd'hui à notre
niveau le fédéral doit trouver 12
milliards de moyens budgétaires 12
milliards d'euros et les entités du sud
sont elles mêmes en difficulté de
l'ordre de 2 milliards ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a une triple crise
financière institutionnelle et politique
parmi les autres pistes possibles un
retour aux urnes mais selon certains
députés
le fossé entre le nord et le sud
pourrait se creuser encore un peu plus
peut-on envisager un retour aux urnes
pour les belges le pays peut-il
continuer son gouvernement qu'en
longtemps éléments de réponse avec dave
sinardet professeur de sciences
politiques à la vub
barroso ne n'est pas exclue elle est de
moins en moins exclu cependant il faut
une majorité à la chambre des
représentants pour organiser de
nouvelles élections et beaucoup de
partis craignent ces nouvelles élections
parce que déjà en mai dernier ils ont
donc tous perdu ces élections tous les
partis qui ont gouverné
bon entre temps donc ils n'ont pas été
capables de former un nouveau
gouvernement dont on peut s'imaginer que
la plupart d'entre eux
perdre encore plus les élections qui
seraient potentiellement organisé il ya
le problème du budget le budget qui l'a
kiki qui est de plus en plus en déroute
en belgique donc si on ne prend pas
d'initiatives ça va s'empirer
il ya beaucoup aussi beaucoup d'autres
défis socio économique climatique de
mobilité et autres grands problèmes qui
peuvent pas être adressées par ce
gouvernement puisqu'il fait ce qui n'est
pas là c'est des choses qui vont quand
même sur le long terme probablement se
faire sentir
j - 2 avant le break site le divorce
entre londres et bruxelles sera
officielle vendredi à 23h mais c'est
sans surprise que les députés européens
ont voté cet après midi à une large
majorité les modalités du traité de
retrait il s'agissait de la dernière
étape majeure dans la ratification de
l'accord trois ans et demi après le
référendum clément hospital aux côtés
des drapeaux 10,28 ligne ou jack
flottant corps au pied du parlement
européen les eurodéputés britanniques
n'en sont pas moins sur le départ je
suis très heureuse parce que maintenant
les gens vont vraiment voir que nous
avons franchi la première étape nous
avons techniquement quitter l'union
européenne et nous avons décidé cela il
ya déjà longtemps
donc c'est vraiment un soulagement dès
le 31 janvier le pays n'aura plus de
commissaire européen ni d'eurodéputés
plus de trois ans et demi après le
référendum
un point de non retour pour le chef de
file du bric site et opposant historique
à l'union européenne
nigel farrage le 31 janvier 2020 nous
quittons l'union européenne pour
franchir un point de non retour
c'est sa toute l'importance de cette
semaine et pour ce qui est de ce que
cela signifie pour nous sur le plan
constitutionnel de notre place dans le
monde
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante depuis qu'henri viii qui nous
a fait sortir de l'église de rome
il nous a fait sortir de l'église
romaine et nous quittons le traité de
rome
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible mais alors à quoi ressemblera
l'union amputé d'un de ses états membres
la perte sera d'abord démographique
l'union européenne verra partir plus de
66 millions d'habitants soit près de 13
% de sa population et plus de 15% de son
pib
sans les britanniques lieu passera en
deux
de la barre symbolique du demi milliard
d'habitants avec 446 millions de
personnes en son sein l'union est
également un membre permanent au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu ainsi qu'une de ces
deux puissances nucléaires
le secrétaire britannique à la défense a
tout de même voulu rassurer ses
partenaires européens ne remet en aucun
cas en cause des questions de sécurité
de l'europe qui est vraiment très
important pour la grande bretagne autant
qu'elle l'est pour les états membres de
l'union européenne
il n'y aura aucun problème et je pense
que vous savez que de relations
bilatérales ou est un solide lorsque
nous sommes dans l'union européenne et
ce sera tout aussi fort après l'union
européenne deux jours avant cette sortie
historique
c'est une journée chargée en émotion qui
attendent des britanniques le parlement
européen vote aujourd'hui pour sceller
le traité de divorce dès le 31 janvier à
23h le royaume uni rentre dans une
période de transition jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pendant laquelle ils
continueront d'appliquer les règles
européennes
un laps de temps pour négocier la
nouvelle relation qu'entretiendrait à
londres et bruxelles
les pêcheurs attendent le break site
avec impatience ils dénoncent les quotas
qui donne accès à leurs zones de pêche à
leurs homologues européens
ces derniers pêche six fois plus de
poissons dont les eaux britanniques que
les ressortissants du royaume uni dans
les eaux de l'union européenne le
gouvernement mauricien présente ce soir
précisément un projet de loi destiné à
mettre fin à l'accès automatique des
navires européens à l'issue des périodes
de transition le vote est prévu une
demain
le royaume uni devrait déterminer le
niveau d'accès des bateaux de l'union
européenne autorisée il ne devrait pas
être gratuit pour tous simplement parce
qu'ils sont là depuis des années et des
années
les règles changent et et nous reprenons
le contrôle de nos propres politiques à
céline au président de l'union populaire
républicaine chantre du fric site
le dernier obstacle sur le break 6 2
vient d'être levé à une écrasante
majorité au parlement européen et donc
le break si tu vas
vendredi le 31 janvier à minuit heure de
paris je les envie beaucoup parce que
maintenant ils peuvent reprendre leur
politique une politique conforme aux
intérêts nationaux conforme à ce que
souhaite le peuple britannique
je rappelle que boris johnson a fait
passer a décidé d'augmenter le smic de 6
2%
le smic britannique va désormais être
supérieurs au smic français ce qui est
interdit par les orientations le rapport
des grandes orientations des politiques
économiques fixés par la commission
européenne à la france qui exige depuis
des années que le smic n'augmente pas
plus vite que l'inflation même plutôt
moins et donc je considère que si nous
nous sortons de l'union européenne eh
bien on pourrait répondre à la crise des
gilet jaune à la crise des retraites
vous savez que les retraites sont exigés
aussi la réforme des retraites est exigé
aussi par l'union européenne et
l'organisation mondiale pour la santé
convoque le comité d'urgence sur le
coronavirus il doit se réunir demain
le but est de déterminer si l'épidémie
constitue ou non une alerte
internationale l'om s a par ailleurs
demandé au monde entier d'agir face au
nouveau virus
depuis son apparition fin décembre en
chine il a fait 132 morts cinq cartes
sont confirmés en france désormais
florian lambert avec pierre pissavy
yvernault
le corona virus continue de se propager
en europe
un premier cas de contamination entre
humains sur le sol européen a été
confirmé en allemagne
il l'aurait été après avoir rencontré
une personne venue de chine dans le
cadre de son travail
contrairement aux autres patients
signalés en europe qui ont quant à eux
été contaminée lors d'un séjour sur le
territoire chinois
le patient en question va bien cependant
il est toujours isolée dans un hôpital
de munich où il est placé sous
surveillance médicale
l' enquête sur la personne contaminée et
conduite avec la plus grande célérité
notamment dans son environnement
familial et professionnel qui ont déjà
été informés le risque de contamination
du patient reste très élevé
particulièrement dans son entourage
familial et dans les entreprises des
alentours qui ont évidemment été informé
en italie les passagers à bord d'un vol
en provenance de hong kong ont été
contrôlés hier par des professionnels de
santé lors de leur arrivée à l'aéroport
de milan
en france un quatrième qui a été avéré
ce mardi le gouvernement français a
annoncé le rapatriement de ses
ressortissants de la ville chinoise de
wuhan
l'avion devrait être normalement à one
jeudi soir donc ça veut dire qu'il part
mercredi avec le décalage horaire il
arrivera jeudi après-midi à one
nous sommes en constitution de l'équipe
médicale qui va accompagner cet avion
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir identifier
sur place il y à des personnes malades
pour qu'elle fasse l'objet d'une prise
en charge particulière et d'un transport
particulier et que nous ne mélangeons
pas
des personnes malades et des personnes
sans symptômes les autorités japonaises
ont également annoncé ce mardi la
présence au japon d'un cas de
contamination chez un homme qui ne s'est
pas rendu en chine mais ayant véhiculé
des touristes en provenance de one perso
de la maladie le nombre de victimes du
coronavirus s'est aggravée et passe
aujourd'hui à 132 morts environ 6000 cas
sont confirmés dans toute la chine selon
un dernier bilan des autorités
il ya un peu plus d'un an royaux
s'autoproclamer président par intérim du
venezuela la recherche de reconnaissance
et d'appui politique il est arrivé lundi
au canada après un déplacement de
plusieurs jours en europe
retour sur sa tournée européenne avec
antoine claireaux en quête de soutien
international le président autoproclamé
du venezuela s'est engagé dans une vaste
tournée à travers le monde et en europe
en particulier à bruxelles
il a défendu le recours aux sanctions
afin de l'aider à prendre la place du
président nicholas maduro
si nous avons la capacité d'appliquer
des pressions aujourd'hui bien que
controversée les sanctions sont les
outils que le monde libre doit utiliser
contre de tels régimes au forum
économique de davos devant une foule
clairsemée juan gadio a de nouveau
estimé être le seul dirigeant légitime
du venezuela
aujourd'hui l'usurpateur n'a pas de
légitimité
alors que l'assemblée nationale que j'ai
l'honneur de présider avec son honorable
député est la seule puissance publique
avoir été élu lors d'un suffrage libre
et démocratique
il a également était de passage à
londres ou encore à paris où il s'est
exprimé devant ses supporters et a été
reçu à l'elysée par emmanuel macron en
espagne par contre sa visite ne s'est
pas vraiment passé comme prévu
juan garrido a été reçu par le ministre
des affaires étrangères mais pas par le
chef du gouvernement socialiste pedro
sanchez ce qui a provoqué des réactions
hostiles de l'opposition de droite
il en a malgré tout profité pour
s'adresser à une partie de l'importante
diaspora vénézuélienne à madrid leur
promettant la victoire contre je cite la
dernière dictature d'amérique latine au
venezuela les aventures de juan garrido
en europe ne sont pas passés inaperçus
c'est la plus grande farce qui ait
jamais été fait en politique au
venezuela où dans le monde
prétendre s'autoproclamer président qui
donc a élu espèce de clown le président
vénézuélien a également profité pour
donner un signe d'ouverture en invitant
des observateurs des nations unies de
l'union européenne et de plusieurs pays
d'amérique latine aux élections
législatives qui se tiendront un peu
plus tard cette année
en attendant le pays est la cible de
toujours plus de sanctions de la part de
washington
une politique que dénoncent
vigoureusement la diplomatie russe
la politique de sanctions des etats-unis
visant le venezuela et sa population qui
a dépassé toutes les limites imaginable
de contre productivité et d'anti
humanité et qui violent depuis longtemps
le droit international ne fait
qu'aggraver la crise socio économique
l'aide et le flux migratoires vers les
pays voisins
cela fait un an que juan garrido s'est
auto proclamé président par intérim du
venezuela depuis les sanctions ont
redoublé contre caracas
il semble que chacun joue la montre le
camp maduro attend de voir se dégonfler
l'emballement de certains pays
occidentaux au tour de juan garrido et
de l'autre côté on attend que les
sanctions économiques rendent la
situation intenable pour le pouvoir en
place
mais au final c'est bien la population
qui paye les pots cassés et avant de
refermer ce journal cette information
concernant wafa chabrout ni la
correspondante de rt en syrie a été
gravement blessé dans la province
d'idlib dans le nord-ouest
l'équipe était en tournage à matam
arrête l nouman localité stratégique
reprise par les forces d'abbas la
journaliste est actuellement hospitalisé
dans un état grave à allah et c'est la
fin de cette édition se retrouvent
demain 7h du matin heure française pour
un nouveau point sur l'actualité
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]